every once or we're a little late but we
had a vote
uh this afternoon and uh thank you
senator lee for working with me and our
two staffs together on this hearing
i called to order this hearing of the
subcommittee on competition policy and i
trust in consumer rights
the title of this hearing is antitrust
applied
examining competition in app stores
i welcome our witnesses in our hearing
we're going to examine the scope
of america's monopoly problem and
discuss what should be done
to protect and foster competition in the
21st century
today we will focus on competition in
what we call the app economy
we will discuss competition relating to
the mobile applications that run on our
smartphones
including revenues generated through app
sales and in-app purchases
as well as app related ad revenues and
sales of design
devices designed to run apps in 2020
global app revenues have been estimated
at more than
580 billion and they are projected to
grow
to more than 900 billion by 2023
in just the first three months of this
year users are estimated to have spent
21 billion dollars on apps from apple's
app store
and around 11 billion on apps from
google's
play store those are billions not
millions and that's 40
higher than last year this is a huge
business
and it's growing and it's growing fast
there's nothing wrong with that
but what's wrong is if we don't have
competition
users spend about 90 percent of their
smartphone internet time on apps
consumers cannot get the same
functionality from a web page
as they can from an app so when you're
tweeting or browsing the web or mapping
your location or looking at a news feed
or listening to music
you're almost always using an app to put
things in perspective in the first three
months of this year's
americans spend an average of more than
four hours a day center lee
on mobile apps you think you were higher
or lower
okay practically all of the apps used by
consumers today are either pre-installed
on
apple devices or devices running
google's android operating system
or downloaded from apple's app store or
google's play store
depending on the consumer's device apps
designed for the iphone can't run on an
android device and android apps cannot
run on an apple device
so there are two separate app ecosystems
apples and googles with each setting all
the rules and extracting commissions
and consumers choose which ecosystem
they want to use when they buy their
smartphone if they buy an iphone they're
with apple for as long as they use that
phone
if they buy an android phone there with
google for the life of that phone
as consumers don't replace smartphones
very often because they are so expensive
app developers who want to reach
consumers on both types of phone must
create
two versions of their apps one for apple
and one for android and the only
practical way for app developers to
reach those
customers is with the permission of
apple or
google unless you are some kind of
computer hacker
which we hope you're not the only way to
download an app onto your iphone
is through the apple app store no other
app stores are allowed and downloading
apps directly from the internet
to avoid the app store a prop process
known as
side loading is prohibited by apple in
every sense it's what we call
a walled garden and by design the app
store has a literal monopoly
on the distribution of apps on apple
devices
while google does allow alternative app
stores and
side loading on android as a practical
matter
the overwhelming majority of app
downloads take place
on the google play store making it by
far the dominant app store on
android devices both apple and google
maintain strict control
over their app stores they decide which
apps can or cannot
exist on their app stores and set the
rules
for how apps operate once they are
downloaded
as a result apple and google operate as
gatekeepers
with the power to decide how or whether
apps can reach iphone
and android users and at the same time
they offer many apps that compete
directly with those sold through
their own app stores of course this
gatekeeper power
can and often is used to provide a
secure environment in which legitimate
apps can be distributed to consumers
but today we will focus on how apple
and google can use their power to one
exclude or suppress
apps that compete with their own
products and
two charge excessive fees that affect
competition
in the app economy as i've said before
just because a company creates a
successful
innovative business that consumers like
doesn't give it a free pass to harm
competition
or ignore our anti-trust laws
both companies also offer their own apps
that compete with the third-party apps
in their app stores including video
streaming apps music apps payment apps
gaming apps and more in some cases
apple and google can build the
functionality of a third-party app into
their operating system
or build an app that is essentially a
copy
apple's app store terms explicitly allow
them
to imitate any of the apps in their
store a practice known as sherlocking
which can render the original competing
app
obsolete both companies also can
help compel app providers that sell
digital content or services in their app
to use their payment process services
the companies then charge commissions
of up to 30 that's right 30 percent
for such in-app purchases the apps are
not
allowed and this is something that
people don't know to inform customers of
or link to payment methods outside of
the app to avoid the commission
in other words consumers are banned from
finding
out if they're in the app that they have
a cheaper alternative
of course we acknowledge that most apps
are not subject to these commissions
most small developers and those who
offer apps that sell physical goods or
services that will be consumed outside
the app like rides on uber
don't pay the commission and they are
probably pretty happy about that
that's fine but focusing high
commissions
on apps that charge for digital services
used on the iphone
ensures that the commission's target on
the very apps
that are most likely to compete directly
with apple's and google's
own offerings and some affected app
developers are complaining that being
forced to use these payment services
with their high commissions
are crippling their ability to compete
with apple and google products on equal
terms
so just because most developers are
happy because they aren't paying
commissions that's fine
it doesn't inoculate the app stores from
the antitrust laws
if they are harming competition with
other developers
some developers have also raised
concerns about the app store's ability
to demote
their placement in app store rankings to
banish their apps from the app store to
withhold or delay approval of app
updates which can limit app
functionality
and to set their own products as
automatic defaults
and when we talk about incentives it's
important to remember that the app
stores
aren't supporting businesses that just
cover the cost
of operating them in 2020 consumers
are estimated to have spent 72.3 billion
in apple app store and 38.6 billion in
google's play store
applying their standard commission rates
to these amounts
nets apple and google billions of
dollars
these concerns have attracted the
attention of enforcers in america and
around the world
we've seen significant reports on this
issue from governments in europe and
australia
in addition to the house anti-trust
subcommittee's digital markets report
there have also been news reports of
investigations by the justice department
and state attorneys general into app
store competition
and state lawmakers in arizona
massachusetts
north dakota my home state minnesota and
other states
have proposed legislation to regulate
app stores
and although we can and should use our
existing anti-trust laws
to address these issues we can also
strengthen our laws
including with my bill the competition
and antitrust law enforcement re
reform act and the exclusionary portions
of that bill
would be very helpful in taking on these
cases
we also have to make sure that the
agents have resources
take on complex matters which have taken
me quite a few minutes to even get
to the guts of explaining this but i
thought it was really important to do
but you can imagine if you're actually
taking on the world's biggest companies
that we've ever known in the world you
actually have to be able to have the
resources to do that
so that is actually tied in with this as
are all anti-trust matters
before those agencies they have to have
the resources
they just can't do this with duct tape
and band-aids
we all appreciate app stores and the
roles that apple and google
have played in helping to create many of
the technologies that have defined our
age
that's great we're not angry about
success
we simply want to make sure that
capitalism keeps going
in a strong strong way that's fair to
everyone yes
but capitalism is about competition it's
about the products coming on it's about
new competitors emerging this situation
to me doesn't seem like that's happening
when you have
two companies really each dominating in
different areas
and where you have companies that are
simply trying to do business
in their own ecosystems or maybe with
apple and google
that are severely hampered from doing it
so with that i turn it over to ranking
member lee and i look forward to hearing
from the witnesses
thanks so much uh chairman klobuchar and
thanks for holding this
hearing thanks to all of you for being
here today the subject
of today's hearing as uh our
chairwoman has just indicated is
an incredibly important one for better
or for worse our smartphones have come
to dominate our social and economic
lives uh and apps
uh are increasingly becoming the most
popular way to use those
devices to communicate in many cases to
make purchases
to stay informed and otherwise manage
our day-to-day affairs
the power that google apple and
a few other large tech companies hold
over the way americans live their lives
is itself simply unprecedented and
legislators on both sides of the aisle
uh are right to be concerned and
and right to be interested in acqui
inquiring into some of these issues
one recent example of this power
involved the total d
platforming of parlor in january
in a matter of days both apple and
google removed
parlor from their app stores just as
amazon pulled the plug on parlor's
web servers they did this
despite parlor's close collaboration
with the fbi in advance of the january's
uh uh sixth events um in order to flag
potential events
and in spite of the much greater
prevalence of planning uh
uh off the horrible events of january
6th uh
on facebook on instagram and on twitter
but both of those apps uh
and and their owners the facebook and
instagram being under one ownership
and twitter another those apps remained
those apps you know
were allowed to stay on
while parlor disfavored by the woke
barons of silicon valley
was just taken down millions of voices
went silent and one potential avenue for
competition
the the the this marketplace for
social media platforms um it just
disappeared into thin air i found this
troubling uh not just because this was
one company
taken down but because of the many
millions of people
uh who had chosen to use parlor
uh were also effectively silenced in
that and i i found it very difficult to
get
good clear answers or any persuasive
answers as to what warranted this action
other than that they could and other
than that they weren't happen or
weren't happy with certain things that
happened but those answers didn't
meaningfully distinguish
parlor from other other social media
sites or from other apps
i engaged with both apple and parlor
almost immediately to try to get to the
bottom
of this and why it was happening apple's
story seemed
to change somewhat over the course of
our discussions
but i i will give apple and do give
apple credit
uh for continuing to work with parlor
and eventually reaching
a uh a resolution that should see
a parlor return to the app store within
coming days
and all eyes now turn to
google and to amazon to see what they'll
do
so like i say i am very pleased with
this outcome
um uh but i'm as pleased with the
outcome
in many ways as i am very dismayed
that it took three and a half months and
the intervention of a united states
senator in order
to get there i uh it's dumbfounding to
me
these are not the actions of
companies that feel like they have
meaningful competition
now i want to be clear um
this is concerning i'm glad they were
able to to resolve
this issue to the extent necessary to
get parlor back
on the app store in the coming days but
it does make me wonder a number of
things um
how many small businesses
and let's be clear that's that's what
many apps start out as
in fact most nearly all start out as
small businesses how many small
businesses
flounder and die because of potentially
pretextual restrictions
imposed on them arbitrarily by
by app store gatekeepers
how many of them and how many never even
get off the ground
we may never know the true cost of
competition
uh and the cost to competition itself
and to innovation and to consumers
i also want to be clear that parlor's d
platforming
was itself not as far as i can tell
an antitrust violation but it might be
symptomatic
of the immense market power held
by a handful of tech companies including
apple and google and amazon
and others when we see this kind of
market power
being used in harmful uh if legal ways
it's only fair to ask whether
it's also being used in illegal ways
that mike hart that might harm
competition
sometimes this is what raises the first
flags
if you see someone acting with
wanton disregard for competitive
forces that might otherwise come into
play
what else could be out there if big tech
is going to
take a side in the culture wars
or in political conversations big tech
should be prepared for the greater
scrutiny that will come with
that unfortunate choice and with that
harmful choice
with this in mind i'm really excited to
participate in today's hearing
and to get to the bottom of this really
pressing question
thank you
thank you very much ranking member lee
um i want to introduce our witnesses
our first witness today is kyle ander
miss drander is the chief compliance
officer and vice president of corporate
law
at apple earlier in his career he was
an attorney at both the federal trade
commission and the antitrust division
of the department of justice our second
witness will be wilson white
mr white is a public policy and
government relations senior council on
google's mountain view policy team
where he is the global public policy
lead for the android
google play payments communications and
hardware businesses
he also leads on the company's global
policy strategy for emerging tech issues
including artificial intelligence
virtual reality
and the internet of things our third
witness
is dr mark cooper dr cooper is director
of research at the consumer federation
of america
where his responsibility for energy
telecommunications and economic policy
analysis
he holds a phd from yale and is a former
yale and fulbright fellow
he is the author of five books and
numerous articles
next will be mr ratio gutierrez
mr gutierrez is the general counsel and
vice president of business and legal
affairs at spotify
he is responsible for overseeing
spotify's global
legal regulatory and government affairs
and serves as corporate secretary
to its board of directors in addition he
had spotify's global
he heads spotify's global licensing
operations
a business function responsible for
commercial licensing activities
with record labels music publishers
performance rights
and other right holders worldwide our
fifth witness
is christian daru ms daru
is the general counsel corporate
secretary and chief privacy officer of
tile inc
she manages legal and government affairs
as well as privacy for tile
and serves on its executive leadership
team
christian started her career as a
commercial litigator with a focus on
consumer
protection and antitrust defense
most recently prior to tiles she was
chief privacy officer of electronic
arts our final witness is jared sign mr
sein currently serves as the chief legal
officer and secretary
of match group where he is responsible
for all legal
compliance and government affairs
functions for match group on a global
basis
prior to joining match group he worked
for expedia as vice president associate
general counsel
where he oversaw all legal aspects of
expedia's
mergers acquisitions joint ventures i
want to thank the witnesses for
appearing today
and i look forward to hearing your
testimony if the witnesses now could
stand and
raise your right hand including our
remote witnesses
do you swear that the testimony you will
give before the subcommittee will be the
truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you god i
do
thank you you will be seated and uh we
will begin
uh with you uh mr ander for a five
minute testimony thank you very much and
thank you for
appearing remotely thank you
chairwoman klobuchar ranking member lee
and members of the subcommittee
my name is kyle ander and i am apple's
chief compliance officer
i appreciate the opportunity to offer
testimony about apple's app store
some of you may have an iphone with you
right now i hope that's the case because
we believe our products deliver the best
possible customer experience
to do that we work constantly to
innovate
the app store is one of our most
important innovations
it is a critical feature of iphone
providing customers access to nearly 2
million apps allowing you to hail a ride
order dinner listen to music and so much
more
all from your iphone amazing as that is
for our customers i think the app
store's real success
is the opportunity is created for
software developers to build and
distribute
all those apps in the first place today
an entrepreneur with a great idea can
use the app store to build an app
and instantly reach customers across the
entire world
all from her home it's easy to take that
for granted
but it wasn't always this way when we
introduced the app store in 2008
creating software was difficult and
often expensive
developers had to pay for the tools they
needed to build and test their products
then they had to distribute it either
over the internet which had
trust and security issues or through
physical disks which require costly
shelf space in brick and mortar stores
it's a little wonder that options were
fairly limited and expensive back then
the app store changed all of that it
truly revolutionized software
distribution
first the app store is curated iphone is
not just a phone
it contains some of your most sensitive
information
photos of your kids financial and health
information
and the controls to your home security
system
and because of that bad actors from
around the world try to infiltrate
devices using malware
that's like a trojan horse that tries to
get into your phone and wreak havoc
we won't tolerate that we review every
app in the app store to make sure it
needs standards for privacy
safety security and performance
and each week we review about 100 000
submissions
and we reject about 40 percent of them
because they don't meet those standards
and we know that our approach works
study after study shows that the iphone
has fewer malware infections than any
other device in the marketplace
second we've invested significantly to
provide developers the tools
they need to build apps that includes
over
250 000 application programming
interfaces
that help unlock the magic of the iphone
and because of that a developer can
build apps that let you deposit a check
by taking a picture of it play a game or
listen to music
with iphones audio and video
technologies or get directions using gps
apple built those and so many other
capabilities in the iphone
and now developers can leverage them for
their apps
so the app store isn't just a store it's
like a studio stocked with canvases
brushes and paint the tools that artists
need to create their works
and it's a gallery where they can
display and sell their creations
and that is how the app store empowers
everyone to build apps
from elementary school kids to small
businesses
not just the big guys third the app
store is a great value for developers
the developer the developer keeps 100
of the money she makes for the vast
majority of apps on the app store
about 85 percent of them the commission
charged to other developers those
selling digital goods
initially was set at 30 percent which is
a competitive rate today
in a far cry from the rates charged for
software distribution
when the app store was launched 12 years
ago
since then we have never raised the
commission
we've always lowered it as we did again
last year for small businesses
today the commission is almost always
just 15
in those instances when it is required
we're proud of the store we've built the
jobs it has created
and the economic opportunity it's
supported
it's the sort of thing that is possible
when competition is fierce and fair
apple after all was started by tinkerers
and dreamers
we became successful over time because
we had an opportunity to compete
we were in a street fight back then and
we still are today
and we like it that way because we know
that competition spurs
innovation and with it more and better
choices for customers
thank you for the opportunity to
participate today i'm happy to answer
any questions you might have
thank you very much mr ander uh next mr
white with google
chairwoman klobuchar ranking member lee
and distinguished senators of the
committee
thank you for inviting me here today to
discuss the google play ecosystem
and the benefits it provides to millions
of american consumers and developers
my name is wilson white and i'm a senior
director on the government affairs and
public policy team at google
in my testimony today i will describe
one how android and google play work
two the ways in which they've
contributed to competition and choice
and three how we fund and sustain the
continued evolution of android and
google play
while helping developers and consumers
first
at google we believe that everyone
should have equal access
to the benefits of mobile devices and we
design android and google play
with freedom openness and accessibility
in mind
since android is an open source
operating system anyone
including competitors are free to use it
without any requirement to pre-install
or download google's apps or other
services thousands of companies
including peloton and jetblue's
in-flight entertainment system
use the android operating system to
build their technologies and their
businesses
device makers and carriers are free to
use android without google play
or google's other services and many of
them actually choose to pre-load
google's apps
alongside their competing apps in fact
more than half of android devices come
pre-installed with more than one app
store
this openness has proven enormously
valuable to device makers
because it allows them to invest in
other ways
innovate in other ways without having to
devout devote resources to building an
operating system
similarly the availability of
third-party software
is important to ensure that mobile
devices meet consumers expectations
a consumer selecting between competing
mobile devices
needs to understand whether their
favorite apps and games will be
available
and actually work on those devices and
that's where app stores come in
in 2012 we launched google play
as our vision for an ideal android app
store
we have a consumer experience an online
storefront where consumers come
to find their best apps and games and a
developer experience
with app development distribution
commerce
and performance analysis tools that help
developers build better apps
and to grow their businesses through
freedom
openness and accessibility today android
and google play
are the foundation of a thriving and
competitive
device and app ecosystem android is
available on
2.5 billion devices around the world
google play has 2 billion 30-day active
users
and millions of companies rely on these
platforms
to reach consumers around the globe
second android has increased competition
and choice across the ecosystem
because of android today a consumer
selecting a mobile device
isn't limited to one or two or even a
handful of alternatives
more than thirteen hundred companies
build android devices
and there are more than twenty four
thousand different android device models
to choose from
and some of these android devices cost
less than a hundred bucks
which has made computing more accessible
to communities
that haven't been well served by the
tech platforms in the past
third our business only succeeds when
our developer partners succeed
and consumers view us as a trusted
destination for digital content
more than 90 percent of the apps in the
google play store are free
free to consumers and we don't charge
for the range of services that google
play provides
unless it results in a sale of digital
content for a developer
and even then only if that sale occurs
within the app itself
we believe this business model supports
entry
and innovation now when our standard fee
does apply it covers everything from
essential security updates
managing app installs and a vast array
of developer tools
to help developers build and to maintain
a global global marketplace
it also reflects the investment that we
make in the platform itself
for example we employ approximately 9
000 people who are dedicated to android
in google play
this fee is also competitive with
industry practices that existed
long before google play was built many
pc
and console physical and other app
stores charge similar fees
and just a few weeks ago we announced
that we were reducing the fee
to 15 on the first 1 million dollars
that all
developers earned on google play
regardless of those developers
sizes now with this change 99
of developers will see a 50 reduction in
their service fees
we believe the value proposition for
google play is a strong one
but if a developer does not agree that
the value proposition is adequate
the openness of android allows those
developer
developers options to display and
distribute their apps through other
means
either directly to consumers or via
other app stores
creating a global platform with access
to all and providing tools for
developers
has always been our goal since we
launched the very first android device
we're proud that our bet on openness has
resulted in success for all involved
we appreciate the committee's interest
in these important issues and i look
forward to answering your questions
uh thank you very much uh mr white and
next up
dr cooper madame chairwoman members of
the committee
my name is dr mark cooper i'm director
of research at the consumer federation
of america
we appreciate the opportunity to to
testify today
and this may be the most important
effort to reform anti-trust in the four
decades that i have been
analyzing it for the cfa i draw on three
articles in my comments which i've
submitted for the record
they outlined the problem which the
remarkably this
chairwoman's description of the
practices were
all illegal in the microsoft case
and that is the standard that we should
be applying today
and enforcing digital communications is
dominated by
platforms using and abusing market power
to undermine competition
six years ago we concluded that one
primary goal of public policy in a
dynamic
digital economy is to ensure that market
power
that is inherent in platform does not
hinder or diminish the competition for
goods and services
and applications that can ride on those
platforms
we have the model in hand bright lines
behind which
entrepreneurial experimentation is
unleashed
and strong antitrust principles to
constrain market power
the great challenge of course is where
do you draw that line
how do you find a set of policies that
recognize that there are innovative
companies
developing platforms and there are
competitors who would like to
develop applications we know that
companies are innovative and these
companies
here and on the tv are innovative they
are seeking
innovative rents sometimes called
shumpentarian rents because they disrupt
business
and they create needs and wants that
they then meet
in increasingly consumer-friendly ways
however there tends to come a point in
the development of these industries
where instead of chasing shupentarian
rents
they begin to chase what i call
rockefeller rents
those are the rents that accrue to firms
that build bigger moats around their
businesses
and lock consumers in while they lock
competitors
out an analysis by the stigler group
uh center at university of chicago lists
three dozen challenges to
do antitrust in the digital age
the irony is that the first 10 represent
positive economic benefits
of digital production and distribution
those are the innovations we need to
foster
but the existence of those innovations
does not justify
the two dozen anti-competitive sets of
practices
that have grown up around them
now congress should in fact set goals
provide authority give power and
resources
to the expert agencies under close
congressional oversight the agencies
will get the job right
however if congress tries to draw lines
and pick winners and losers
there's a good chance that the winner
they pick today will be a loser tomorrow
and then we have to get congress to act
again and that is not so easy to do
congress should clear away the thicket
of mergers and
abusive practices the decades of
antitrust malpractice and
shift direction it should put all of the
suspect practices and mergers on the
table
and empower the agencies to figure out
who
is doing what to whom and quickly
resolve those problems
the specifics that i support in my
testimony include the following
non-discriminatory intervention
interconnection and garage
which equals open application interfaces
in the digital economy deep suspicion of
proprietary application interfaces that
presumption that they are
illegal and severe risk to those
platforms that rely on proprietary
interfaces
fair reasonable and non-discriminatory
rates terms and conditions
for access that's friend an expression
you'll hear in antitrust
but the demand side is as important as
the supply side
if we can't get the customers it doesn't
matter how many apps we can develop
as long as we if we can't win the
business
so we need to have the equivalent which
is true consumer sovereignty on the
demand side
consumers must have opt in not opt out
no presumption of what the default is
give me the chance to choose
equal single click choice provision of
neutral information
clear description of the information
that's collected and how it is used
and some limitations on the types of
information
collected and the targeting of groups
for that information those are the
principles
approximately 10 principles that need to
govern this space
if it is going to be consumer-friendly
and competitive thank you
thank you very much dr cooper next
mr gutierrez chairwoman klobuchar
ranking member lee and members of the
subcommittee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today on behalf of spotify
my message is simple stark and urgent
we believe all businesses including
spotify
should work hard to earn the favor of
consumers
through fair and square competition in
the marketplace
based on better more innovative products
offered at attractive prices but apple
abuses its dominant position as a
gatekeeper of the app store
to insulate itself from competition
and disadvantage rival services like
spotify
apple's anti-competitive conduct hurts
consumers with higher prices
less innovation and less choice our
market moves at internet speed
and legislative action is urgently
needed to give
antitrust enforcement agencies the tools
they need
to prevent gatekeeper platforms like
apple from abusing the power of their
platform
and unless decisive legislative and
enforcement action is taken
other gatekeeper platforms inevitably
will follow
apple's example resulting in further
concentration of power
in the hands of a handful of digital
sovereigns
15 years ago spotify pioneered
a streaming audio service that today
enables
our 345 million customers to hear the
music and podcasts they want
anywhere at any time apple music is one
of our principal competitors
its advantage is not better service
instead it is apple's total control over
the app store
which allows them to impose rules that
disadvantage spotify
and benefits apple's own service some
may not remember this
but iphones weren't that popular when
first introduced
apple soon realized that the iphone
would not succeed
if it only offered apple's proprietary
apps
and it invited third parties to develop
apps for the iphone
and open the app store apple therefore
has things exactly
backwards when it claims that companies
like spotify
are free riding on apple's innovations
it is apple's success
that wrote in large part on the
creativity of third-party app developers
that created demand for apple's devices
and the proof is apple's own slogan
there's an app for that
which it used to drive sales of apple
devices
how did apple show its gratitude for app
developers help
by doing a classic bait and switch they
waited until tens of millions of device
owners
were locked into the iphone before
changing the app store rules
to impose burdens on app developers that
compete
with apple's own applications apple has
a decade-long history
of using app store policies to handicap
spotify
and benefit apple music it forced us to
choose between two bad
options accepting apple's illegal tie of
its proprietary payment system
and paying apple's 30 tax which would
have forced us to raise consumer prices
and made our service more expensive than
apple music
or accepting a gag order prohibiting our
communication with our own customers
so that we can't tell our users about
the existence of our premium service
discounts and promotions available to
first-time subscribers
now it doesn't take a phd in economics
to recognize
that this abuse of conduct hurts
consumers by depriving them of
information
about a product that competes with
apples
apple's anti-competitive intent is clear
from the fact that it targets businesses
that
are or might become apple's competitors
in downstream markets the rules apply to
companies that offer
online gaming music and video streaming
access to ebooks but companies like uber
starbucks ticketmaster and walmart are
exempt
apple argues that these rules are
indispensable
to the safety and privacy of users but
how can they be indispensable
when they don't even apply to 85 of the
apps in the app store
that are exempt from apple's
restrictions apple's explanations are
cynical pretexts
these restrictions are nothing more than
an abusive power grab
and a confiscation of the value created
by others
even microsoft in the heyday of the
windows pc
operating system did not demand a cut
of 30 of the revenues of competing
browsers
and media players legislative action is
urgently needed
to stop these illegal power grabs we
welcome the broad antitrust reform
proposed by chairwoman klobuchar
along with senators blumenthal and
booker
senator hawley recently proposed a bill
with a number of similar
and very important reforms these reforms
are essential to equip
enforcement agencies with the tools they
need to
remedy the market and consumer harms
that result from these platform abuses
thank you and i look forward to
answering your questions
very good thank you very much ms daru
thank you to the subcommittee and to
your dedicated staff for convening this
critical hearing
my name is kirsten deru and i'm the
general counsel of tile
kyle helps people find lost items our
devices work with the tile app to help
people find their keys wallet purse
really anything
we also embed our technology into
third-party products like
headphones laptops and wearables we're a
small company with only
with less than 150 employees but we
pioneered this category and found
success even in the face of significant
competition
ranging from other startups to fortune
50 companies
much of our success relates both to
world-class features and a commitment to
both privacy
and importantly interoperability we
believe consumers should have a
seamless finding experience across any
platform
including android and iphone originally
we had a symbiotic relationship with
apple
we launched our ios app in 2013 they
sold our devices in their retail stores
and they even featured us on stage at
their worldwide developer conference in
2018
but that all changed when apple decided
that it wanted to take over this
category
to be clear we welcome competition but
it has to be fair competition
and apple's idea of competing is
patently unfair and i will give you some
examples
with ios 13 apple introduced a new find
my app
that had tile features that
is basically their version of tile find
my is installed by default on all
iphones at the exact same time apple
made changes to its operating system
that denigrated our user experience and
made it really hard for our customers to
activate their tiles
but they left find mice streamlined and
on by default
apple reserved troves of critical
information
for use exclusively in find my and not
competing apps
and then of course yesterday apple
announced the launch of their competing
hardware product
the airtag air tags will make use of a
technology called ultra wide band or uwb
it's a non-proprietary technology in the
same way that bluetooth is
but whereas bluetooth can tell you in
what room your item is located
uwb can tell you exactly what pillow
it's under
apple first included uwb chips in its
iphone 12
and since 2019 we have made
many requests to access that chip so
that we can
use it for the benefit of our customers
in fact
we made an amazing experience using
augmented reality with uwb
where you can use your phone and see
exactly where
in the room what pillow your your keys
are located under
but apple refused our requests and
therefore we cannot bring that
innovation
to the market for the benefit of our
customers
yet the air tag is going to
use uwb because apple's decided to
reserve its use
exclusively in its product if that
weren't enough
two weeks ago apple confirmed that it's
about to go live with something called
the find my network accessory program
which the house has already found to be
anti-competitive
the program was originally touted in the
media as a pro
competitive concession to tiles concerns
giving our customers
access to the troves of location data
otherwise reserved for find my
not so in order for our customers to get
that benefit
we have to give apple unprecedented
control over our business
and direct our customers to the find my
app to find their lost items
basically the find my program holds
critical data hostage
to coerce developers like tile to
abandon our apps
and our networks it deprives customers
of choice
and importantly it breaks our
interoperability
this isn't surprising in the epic
litigation an apple employee named find
my friends as part of apple's strategy
to decrease interoperability to lock
customers into its ecosystem
it seems as though find my is part of
apple's ongoing plan to turn
ios into a hotel california where you
can check in anytime you like
but you can never leave and it's working
one of our competitors has um has
actually
announced that its newest devices will
be available
exclusively within find my to the
exclusion
of its own app apple of course claims
that all of these actions are necessary
in the name of privacy
that is not true privacy and fair
competition are not
mutually exclusive apple could
easily define requirements to allow us
all to play on the same field
but apple doesn't do that apple uses
privacy as a blanket excuse
to subject competitors to different
rules
this is what happens when you have a
monopolist
acting as a de facto regulator the
regulations will always
favor the monopolist if apple turned on
us it can turn on
anyone and apple has demonstrated it
won't change
unless someone makes them and the
legislative answer is simple
if apple chooses to compete against
developers on its platform it should
just do so fairly
and according to the same term same
rules
regulating a giant like apple won't be
easy but it's just going to get harder
as it gets bigger and more powerful
starting with an app store antitrust
reform bill to address some of these
known abuses will be an important first
step
to ensure lasting innovation and
competition in this country
thank you for your time
thank you very much next mr sign last
but not least thank you
madam chair ranking member lee and
members of the committee
thank you for your bold leadership in
advancing this important public debate
apple and google have used their
monopoly power to redirect the
meritocracy of the free
competitive and innovative information
super highway
to run primarily through the toll gates
of their app store monopolies
they have systematically programmed
users to seek out the app for that
and if you do not have an app you might
as well not exist
let me be clear apple and google are the
only gatekeepers of this new internet
using user data and app developers
innovations
and even income against them in order to
bankroll the construction
of massive tollways on the formerly free
information super highway
at the heart of this strategy to control
developers and consumers
is the requirement that app developers
use apple's and google's
in-app payment services or credit card
processor
for which they charge a whopping 30
percent tax
but don't take my word for it the late
apple ceo steve jobs devised this
strategy
back in 2010 apple grew wary that it was
far too simple for users to switch
between
ios and android devices because app
developers were allowing users to buy
services directly from them
that could be used readily on either
platform
his directive was simple let's force
them
to use our payment system he knew that
once users paid through apple
and not the app developer they would be
locked into apple's ecosystem
tying their purchases to their ios
devices and forcing app developers to
hand over the lifeblood of their
businesses
their customer relationships let me
share just two examples of our
experiences
that unequivocally demonstrate the
monopoly power of these app stores
shortly after google launched the google
play store they pursue
they persuaded us to join the android
ecosystem
under the false pretenses of an open
platform where we would not be required
to use
google's payment processor or pay the 30
tax now years after helping them
establish
their app store monopoly by bringing our
apps
and our customers to the play store
google is leveraging
its monopoly power to change the rules
tying its in-app payment system
to our access to the play store starting
in september of this year
not to be outdone apple has been equally
authoritarian
a few years back match wanted to
institute id verification rules in our
taiwanese app
that mirrored those already required in
japan
apple rejected our app perplexed
i personally contacted the app store's
head lawyer to explain why this was the
right thing for our business
and why it kept our users safe i was
told in no uncertain terms that he
disagreed with our assessment
of how to keep our users safe he added
that we should just be glad
that apple is not taking all of match's
revenue telling me
you owe us every dime you've made
i was floored senators this is not
curation
as we've been told it is iron fisted
monopoly control
when an industry player has the power to
dictate how apps operate
how much they will be forced to pay and
in many cases if they will even survive
it is a monopoly this is the same
behavior of the robber barons before
them
it is no wonder that so few companies
have been willing to stand up and
testify against these monopolies
would you take that risk if you were a
small business
these monopoly activities result in many
harms to app developers and consumers
but i'll focus specifically on four
first
safety is actually harmed in the current
system
because of apples and google's
stranglehold on consumer data
it's difficult for us to even conduct
the most basic safety checks for our
apps
for example despite multiple requests
over the years
apple and google still allow underage
users to download our apps
even when they know they are under 18.
apple and google actually make it harder
for us to keep our users safe
number two apples and google's in-app
payment rules force users to hand over
massive treasure troves of their most
sensitive data
which these tech tyents tech titans can
use to enrich their own products
or develop their own competing digital
services nearly overnight
and charged 30 percent less number three
the app store tax today instead of
there's an app for that
google's and apple's practices could be
better described as there's a tax for
that
the 30 percent tax levied on every
digital transaction
increases costs on consumers and
developers alike for match these app
store fees are our single largest
expense
eclipsing half a billion dollars
annually that's
500 million dollars that could be going
back into the pockets of everyday
employees
or excuse me everyday consumers or
deployed to hire employees
or invested in new innovations
number four incentivizing the
monetization of selling user data and
reducing innovation
apple and google essentially push
developers to adopt a less privacy
friendly business model
incentivizing them to avoid mandatory
in-app payment
by operating more like facebook where
consumer data is the commodity and
monetized
additionally by removing competition in
the payment space
innovation is harmed when the veneer of
their safety
security and privacy arguments shatter
under the weight of scrutiny
apple and google respond that they built
the platforms
and should be able to decide what
business models they use
members of the committee i submit that
the railroad companies build the
railroads
the steel companies built the steel
mills the telephone companies built the
telephone lines
the creators of all of these incredible
innovations each made the same argument
at different times
it did not justify a monopoly then and
it should not today
thank you and i look forward to
answering your questions
thank you very much that was very
powerful mr sign as was
all the witnesses before us so um let me
uh start out here with you mr gutierrez
uh both apple and google uh charge app
developers
a 30 to 15 percent commission fee for
processing
in-app purchases of digital services
both companies point out that the
majority of apps do not
pay any payment uh processing commission
because they are free apps or because
they're selling non-digital products or
services
but many of those who must pay the
commissions find them duly burdensome
and i'm concerned that these commissions
can be used to suppress competition
when they raise the cost of app
developers that compete with the apps or
other products or services that are
offered by the app
store operator spotify has raised
concerns
about the competitive impact about these
commission fees
can you describe the effect of these
in-app commission fees
what effect it's had on spotify's
ability to compete
and can you just pass these fees on to
consumers
thank you senator um thank you for your
question
we um there was a time in which
under pressure from apple we had to
implement apples
in a payment service and as a
consequence of that had to start paying
the 30 apple tax
the consequence of that in in a business
like ours where so much of our revenue
has to go to pay for the licensing of
content from
artists and music labels and others is
that in fact we had no choice but to
increase our price
to be able to afford the 30 tax that
apple was imposing on us
so we had to raise our consumer prices
from a monthly subscription of 9.99
to 12.99 unbeknownst to us
as apple was putting pressure on us to
do that apple was in the process of
acquiring
beats music rebranding it as apple music
and then just a couple of months after
um
we had to increase prices apple launched
apple music at 9.99 which meant they
were now
undercutting us on price because
we had to pay the 30 tax to apple
so faced with this reality in which
apple was now putting us in this
uncompetitive situation from a consumer
price perspective
we had no choice but to take the iap
functionality now
what followed after that was a series of
steps on the part of apple threatening
us
to kick us out of the app store just
imagine the
the power of a threat on the part of a
platform like apple
to take you out of the app store what
that might mean for your
business a number of steps in which they
not only said
it wasn't enough for us not to provide a
link
to a payment mechanism but we couldn't
even
tell users that there was a subscription
option
and that they were discounts that we
were offering that would make the
product
cheaper this gag order in terms of the
communication with our own customers
which makes it incredibly hard for us to
persuade the user of a free app
to upgrade to a subscription app
which is frankly in a freemium model
like ours
how the business can work and how the
creators that put their content
on our platform can be fairly
compensated this is a very
clear i want to keep going it's an
amazing story
um and at some point i'll go to mr
anders here to explain this but
there's another piece of this um is that
you know not only are you charge these
fees then
you're you're forced to pass them on
when you don't want to
um but it's my understanding that the
app stores
bar app providers like spotify from
telling your customers
through the app that your services would
be cheaper if they could directly buy
them
online and if those marketing bans were
eliminated
what would you tell your users and how
do you think it could affect them
well that that that is a super important
issue because
our communication with our user is the
way in which we get the
get them to know about the opportunities
they have
about subscription and if we can't do
that then we can't
uh make the the the the uh the freemium
model work and apple knows that
because they're in the business okay
exactly the importance of that all right
um uh mr sein
uh match had a program which you
testified about
um or um which called
t-mobile tuesdays that offer discounts
through t-mobile's app is that right
that's correct um apple shut it down as
i understand it
is that right that's correct they block
t-mobile's app okay and so if apple
changed its rules to allow match to
offer discounts
uh would you do so and how would that
work 100
we actually already offer for example on
our tinder uh
app if you subscribe through the website
you get a discount relative to what you
would pay in the app so
that already exists we would 100 percent
take advantage of that if we could
okay uh ms darwin you testify nehru you
testified that apple essentially copied
tiles act
and took steps to undermine tiles
functionality by changing the iphone
operating system to favor their
competing product and by limiting cow's
access to data
and yesterday apple announced the launch
of a new product that looks a whole lot
like tile
can you elaborate on the ways in which
apple's conduct has reduced tile's
ability to compete
absolutely and thanks for the question
all of these actions really started when
it became known to us
that apple was going to you know enter
the market and
attempt to take it over but really what
they did was
with the exact same operating system
update that they
introduced the new find my app
they took away one of our critical
permissions which requires our customers
to go
deep deep deep into their settings to
turn
tile on find my by contrast
is on by default through the when you
set up your operating system
and in order to turn it off you have to
go deep into your settings
and actually enter a password um
apple also started serving prompts with
that same update
um to our users once they figured out
how to turn tile on they started serving
these prompts encouraging them to turn
tile off but they didn't serve up those
prompts for find my um
our bluetooth network of course people
need to opt in to the bluetooth network
i think that's great we are
complete supporters of consumer
transparency
um but the find my bluetooth network in
the new find my app
is on by default and then with these air
tags as i discussed
we have the uwb issue which i won't
repeat
but there's something else it's called
something they call the magic onboarding
flow to connect your your
air pot or your air tags with your phone
you don't even have to open the find my
app you just put them near
but that magic flow isn't available to
third parties like tile
in addition to all of that you know
apple launched this product and um and
it's its competing
app with a knowledge of a lot of
information about
our business they know our retail take
rates they know our mark retail margins
they know how our
devices do in stores they know who our
customers are they know
our subscription take rates they know
what features people use
i mean the list goes on and on and that
is another concern thank you all right
um so one of the things that i've
noticed as we talked to
uh people affected by all of this and
the commission fees and the like
they've come forward and a lot of them
i'm not going to give their names
publicly because
um they're actually afraid to testify i
guess i don't blame them because
um they feel that it's gonna hurt their
business they're gonna get intimidated
uh you uh mentioned um mr gutierrez i'm
not asking you this question
um some of the retaliation you thought
that that you felt you
experienced coming forward mr stein
have you have any examples of
retaliation for
coming forward
senator we have that outreach with
respect to our coming forward
sure um uh by google
oh what happened um
uh they called us last night after our
testimony became public
to ask us why our testimony was
different than what we'd said about the
situation in our earnings call earlier
this year
is it different what we said in our
earnings call earlier this year was that
we believed we would be able to work
through the issue of
google imposing their 30 on us which
we've been working very hard at over the
last few years meeting with regulators
and
others to try and change these practices
and ensure this from not happening
google actually first threatened us in
2017
that they would roll out this um in-app
payment requirement to us
and they've slowly uh or they've slow
rolled that until they announced it last
september so
and so i'm just picturing this compared
to australia where they threatened
to cut off a whole country uh simply
because they wanted to charge for
content
and so if you were to somehow keep
experiencing retaliation i would assume
there's i don't we don't i don't want to
keep going into my time we have several
senators here
uh three more another one on the way i
just want to know
you know could they hurt you in little
ways that it would be really hard to
detect they could hurt us in little ways
they could hurt us in big ways
uh you know they could easily remove our
app they could
again as they're doing impose the 30 tax
that they had never imposed on us before
there are many many ways they can hurt
our businesses we we're all afraid as
the reality senator
um we're fortunate you are listening to
us today well
and i hope the justice department is too
mr white why did someone from your
company
call mr sein you know match is a major
uh competitor here in the market we all
know who they are why'd they do that
last night
uh thank you senator for the question
and and not only is uh
matcha a competitor batch is a major
partner of ours a very valued partner of
ours
my understanding uh uh based on uh what
mr sein said is it sounds as if
some business development folks who are
working on commercial uh conversations
had a conversation and asked an honest
question
of why uh uh sworn testimony was
different from
what was stated in a public earnings
call i i respectfully don't
view that as a threat and we would never
threaten our partner senator
having developers uh choosing to
distribute through google play is core
to our business
so the idea that we would threaten
partners who actually uh
share in the success that we have as a
platform it's the is antitypical it's
the
it's the antithesis of what uh how we
carry our business senator
okay my last question we'll have another
round mr ander
um uh this is about some of the things
that miss daru talked about um does
apple's developer agreement
authorize apple to use an app
developer's confidential technical and
business information to create apps
that compete against the developer
but senator no it does not we compete on
the merits
uh and we've looked at different
products different markets
and we ask ourselves time and time again
what can we
do different what can we bring as unique
and special
to the marketplace and i think air tags
is one of those products
we think it's a very different product
than anything else that's out there
we're super excited to launch this
product tomorrow
and i think if you look at it you'll see
that it's extremely different than
anything else in the marketplace
we're doing at the same time is opening
up the find my network so we can see
third party innovation grow
i mean currently this market is
dominated by tile with 80 to 90 percent
of the market
so we think we're going to see a lot
more competition thanks in part to the
product that we're launching
tomorrow but also importantly by opening
the find my network to all the third
parties that are out there
and are really excited to bring products
together do you use any non-public
information
or data from the app store
did you copy anything from tile uh
senator appreciate the question
absolutely not we did not copy
tiles product we did not copy tiles
application i think if you
look at the air tags that will be
released tomorrow
if you look at the find my application
you'll see this is a very different
product
very different experience than what you
see with tile and we're excited to
compete
and offer that choice to our consumers
and why do you have to
charge 30 percent to spotify
uh senator i appreciate the opportunity
to respond to that
uh the fact of the matter is that
spotify has grown an incredibly
successful business
uh and to their credit they're
incredibly innovative and
incredibly aggressive when it comes to
dealing with artists and creators and
driving a hard bargain
they equally drive a hard bargain with
distributors
and they've built the market leading
dominant music streaming
business in the world uh we in terms of
subscribers
they have 155 million subscribers around
the world
tens of millions of those are on the
iphone less than
one percent pay a commission to apple
and in fact they're only paying a 15
commission so the price that
mr gutierrez mentioned in terms of
increasing it by 30
guess what they've never reduced that
price once for their consumers
and so hey they're a great company
they're pushing us to compete each and
every day
um but i i i respectfully think you know
we're offering choice
in in options to our consumers
i'm just thinking they didn't bargain
for that much money of a
30 i'm going to turn over to senator lee
thank you madam chair um ms darling
let's
start with you um talk a little bit
about air tag
and um uh by the way i'm
i i've used your product it's a
fantastic product it's very
wonderful to a lot of people um
so i want to make sure i understand this
correctly did apple
start treating tile differently in
advance of the product launch is that
what you're saying
uh that is correct now i understand that
apple requires companies like tile
including tile to sign an agreement to
be part of the find my network
correct what can you tell me about what
that um
what that agreement requires
unfortunately i
am not at liberty to say because i'm
under an nda by apple
okay um mr mr ander
will you agree to allow ms darrow to
talk about
find my network agreement
uh senator you know obviously that
agreement covers a number of proprietary
technologies
uh and work that we're still developing
here at apple
uh so i can't grant a blanket waiver uh
to discuss it because there's a number
of
uh proprietary technologies and issues
involved in that agreement
could you grant a waiver to the extent
it
doesn't include disclosing proprietary
technologies
i mean our focus in this hearing is uh
to discuss the state
of competition and competition policy as
it relates to
app stores is there not a way to craft
that waiver uh i i'm sure there is
senator uh it's a little hard to do this
in
in in the moment in the vacuum um but
certainly you know
general commercial terms you know again
those are still being hashed out
we're interested in contractual
limitations
not on intellectual property correct
just contractual terms
no technology um nothing to
technology related at all so so
uh just just to be clear um
mr andrew your response related to
your proprietary technology to your to
your ip
i didn't hear you say anything about
your contractual limitations which is
what we're wanting to re inquire into
is your answer still the same senator
part of the challenge here for me
frankly is
we just launched this program two weeks
ago we are in the midst
of talking about it with a number of
different parts sure no i understand you
just launched it
but it's not like it it materialized
like manna from heaven it didn't just
show up
that's correct but right now we're
collecting feedback from a number of
developers we're
we're engaged with dozens of third
parties
who are really excited to use this
technology and giving us feedback
on all of these terms um so i'm in a bit
of a difficult position
okay well i i'd i'd appreciate it if you
could look into that
again we're not we have no interest in
we have no jurisdiction over
uh ip aspects of it we want to know
about your contractual
obligations there mr simon in your
written testimony
suggests that apple and google have
refused
to work with you in order to improve um
user
safety tell us a little bit about more
about what you mean by that
yeah so you know first and foremost the
issue i raised in my testimony was about
underage users we are a
platform that is decided because we're
online dating it's appropriate for only
users that are 18 and older
apple and google collect information as
users are registering for their itunes
accounts or their other accounts through
which they will actually
download those apps in many instances
they actually know the age of those
users and if you're a user and you move
through that flow
and you're 15 years old you'll get a
pop-up that says
by clicking here you're agreeing that
you're over 18. even though
apple knows you're not because you've
already entered your birthdate is 15.
those get passed on to our app
we then have to filter them out through
our various age gating systems
in order to make sure that we don't have
underage users on our platforms
right i've encountered that
one of my teenagers a few years ago when
i was arranging
uh to pay her allowance i tried to do it
through apple pay we couldn't do it at
the time
she wasn't 18 at the time that would
suggest that they do in fact know which
user
you to have an iphone to operate with an
iphone you've got to have an itunes
account
if it's a miner it can be linked to an
adult's account it was
it knows that she was a miner correct uh
we even tried to jerry riggett
go around it and it wouldn't let us
because it knows
so that that that is troubling um
if uh or that that is significant at
least
if they do know this and knowing that
and allowing
that to be known could be useful for the
purpose
of protection we live in a world where
people do a lot of bad things to kids
it's hard for me to understand why they
wouldn't want to share that information
we agree senator you know in addition
our platforms for years have run
registered sex offender checks
uh we've asked apple and google to share
the data with us that would make it
easier to run those checks and again
um there has been well some lip service
to it very little work done we've then
gone around them in order to speak with
people here in the senate uh to try and
help craft legislation that would
actually allow us to be able to run
those checks with
with different data we've also helped to
support a bill that passed in arizona
that would allow us to get access to
that data to go around the fact that
apple and google don't share the
information we need
in order to run those checks
mr ander and and mr white now
as has been noted we've got ride sharing
apps that use the internet to help you
find
transportation in the real world um
matches dating apps use the internet to
help you find
a date in the real world why does match
have to use
your payment services and give up
30 or 15 of its revenue
but uber does not let's start with mr
white and then go to mr
andrew thank you senator lee uh for the
question
it's um uh and it's a good one very
important question
the way the way we've designed our
business model is to to align our
interests with our developer interests
so we only get paid when our developers
are engaging in the sale of digital
digital content and only when that uh
sale occurs in the app itself
now when it comes to physical goods and
services
we aren't in a position to really uh
protect users
on what happens in the physical world
right we won't know whether that uber
driver arrived on time or whether your
groceries
uh arrived in an acceptable state but
when it comes to digital content that's
where
our investments have been that's where
our value add is
and that's why we've chosen the business
model to align our interests
with developers who are actually selling
digital content
to our shared users
mr anderson
senator thank you apple's app store was
created
12 years ago based on a simple model
that is
if you're selling a digital good or
service you were subject to a commission
now obviously we've made changes to that
model over time in terms of making it
easier for
developers to sell outside of uh their
app
in terms of reducing the price over time
when it comes to this question about
physical goods or services like using
uber to call a car
to your house to pick you up and take
you to the airport or
a lift to go and meet friends for that
you're using a phone to communicate with
the service provider
and they're delivering that service to
your home or your location
when it comes to a dating service uh in
you know obviously tinder has built
quite a successful business and
they have a number of these sites what
they're doing is facilitating
uh meeting with people digitally all of
that's taking place
at least should be on the device that is
you're finding a match you're meeting
someone you're swiping right or
all that taking place on the device so
from our perspective
and from really the perspective of all
the developers we've talked to
that's a digital good or service that is
not a physical good or service being
delivered to your house
yeah now what if what if your business
involves the downloading
of some other digital service the
downloading of ebooks
of audiobooks or something like that
is that if you're saying it's a digital
service
wouldn't that extend to the purchase
of downloads of books uh
yes uh senator yes it does
uh and folks like amazon and they're
very popular kindle app
right so how is that different than
match.coms apps
they're both selling a digital good or
service one
is a book uh the other is a subscription
to a service where you're meeting other
people that you may be interested in
okay so uber that is also
a digital service in the sense that
you're trying to find a ride
now you're also paying for that ride
it involves movement of the person once
the right involve
arrives but in all three instances
downloading of books arranging to meet
someone to date
or finding a ride aren't those all three
digital services where you're exchanging
information through the app
senator respectfully i see the car
service very differently
than the dating service or the audiobook
the dating service you're meeting people
on your phone
on the book you're reading the book on
your phone or your ipad
with the car service i am calling a car
to my house to come pick me up
and take me to to work or to the airport
or wherever i might be going
the value i'm getting from uber and lyft
is a way to get a car to go from a to d
in terms of the other examples all of
the experience
is contained within the four corners of
the device
uh you're not paying but uber is
literally meeting a stranger for
transportation
i i just i'm not grasping the
differentiation point between meeting a
stranger for transportation
and meeting a stranger to go to dinner i
i don't i don't get it i'm just a
small country lawyer from provo utah but
i i'm not oh yeah right
senator respectfully you know when i'm
using
uber or lyft i am calling a car to my
house to physically get in it
and drive somewhere when i'm using and i
don't use these
uh a dating service to meet someone i'm
not using it to pay
that person to come to my house and to
go on a date
uh that that that's called something
else
i i feel like unfrozen caveman lawyer as
portrayed by
phil hartman and saturday night live
i've just i'm i'm not grasping it but i
see my times expired and i want to be
differential towards here
thanks very good um next senator
blumenthal
thank you madam chair woman uh i'm just
a
country lawyer from connecticut
uh i tried to use that line once
senator lee in the supreme court in an
argument there and i think it's
the closest i came to contempt of court
anyway
uh let me just say
uh after listening to
my colleagues i'm tempted to say
google and apple are here to defend
the patently indefensible if you
presented this fact pattern
in a law school antitrust exam
the students would laugh the professor
out of the
classroom because it's such an obvious
violation
of our antitrust laws mr gutierrez you
remark in your testimony that
you were at microsoft during what you
call the heyday of its antitrust woes
i remember those days because i sued
microsoft
and the lesson from that case that you
expound here that these practices are
exponentially worse
is absolutely true but the larger lesson
that you tell us that
the current laws aren't working in
effect
that enforcement of them is too little
too late
courts are overly deferential agencies
are reluctant to bring lawsuits
and therefore we need to reform our laws
is the takeaway here
that's correct senator i i think that
the one has to appreciate
both from the point of view of the legal
tools of being able to overcome this
differential approach
and the tasks that the enforcement
agencies would have to do that
you also have to recognize that in this
case you would be looking
at the business and the practices of
trillion dollar companies
that have a global footprint with a
tremendous information asymmetry
so both from the point of view of the
legal tools that the enforcement
agencies need
as well as from the point of view of
resourcing
i think if something meaningful is going
to happen those things have to be looked
at
and what i heard
apple tell you in defense of charging
you this rent whether it's 15
or 30 percent hardly makes any
difference it's rent
arbitrarily imposed to try to stifle
competition and increase apple's profits
at your expense
is well you can afford it
but the fact of the matter is that as
you said
spotify has to pass it on to consumers
and it inhibits innovation
and competition correct that's correct
and apple knows
the business really well because they're
in it they're a direct competitor of
ours
and this is a textbook textbook case of
racing rivals cost
which is what they're doing they
recognize because they know the music
streaming business that we have
high cost associated with paying for the
content to the artists and
musicians and they know that our margins
are
tight and that a 30 tax even if it
eventually might come down to 15 percent
it is just
too large a fee uh to be able to absorb
uh without passing on that
uh increase to consumers and just to
show you that apple is well aware of the
value of this practice
it doesn't allow users to jailbreak
their phones to side load apps it has
shut down alternative app stores
in fact uh as we know apple was sued by
an alternative app store
cydia on monopolization grounds
insidious complaint makes clear that
apple not only excluded
them from the iphone market but lifted
city as popular features and
incorporated them
into apple's app store so it's not
only a matter of making you charge
consumers more
it's also a method to suppress
competition and steal
good ideas correct that's correct and
and senator
just to follow on on your point if apple
is convinced that their
payment system is that superior that it
really should command a thirty percent
fee
they should allow for company
competition let the market determine
that
let supply and demand determine what the
right fee is but they haven't done that
they have well they
really do that's right they haven't done
it because
the law hasn't been enforced against
them what we have is a classic case of
exclusionary anti-competitive conduct
and as i think all of us would agree
violations of the law and
monopolistic abuse of power just as it
happened in
the microsoft case need to be held
accountable that's why i support
strengthening section two of the sherman
act
to curb anti-competitive exploitive
conduct conduct by
monopolists and other dominant companies
and that's why we need to consider
also interoperability
as a remedy like it was in the microsoft
case and
in the access act that i have
co-sponsored
with senator warner
mr sein uh
we have this apparent explanation of the
call to you
last night right the call was not to me
the call was to
our person who has a business
relationship with
google so it's our uh our representative
talking to their
account representative a representative
of your company correct
out of what do you think idle curiosity
why was the call made
i i can't really speculate on it senator
but
you know any time you receive anything
well we we
are plausibly interpreting it because of
the timing because the content of the
call
uh we don't have evidence of the exact
word spoken but it
looks like a threat it talks like a
threat
it's a threat when you receive something
like that senator from a company that
can turn you off overnight you're always
a little intimidated
correct and it hasn't been reluctant to
throw its weight around similarly
i think it's an insult to this committee
i think it's more than insults
uh potentially actionable and i think we
should look into more information about
it would you agree
we would be happy to comply and work
with you on that that's the plan senator
blumenthal thank you
thank you madam chair i thought it
probably would be thank you
yes uh let me uh
turn to another area that uh
senator klobuchar has ably it's begun to
explore
uh i didn't hear an answer to
senator klobuchar's question mr ander
has apple ever used app developers
information to inform
its own product strategy
uh senator i am not aware of anyone at
apple using proprietary
information from the app store to
develop our products
it's the antithesis of how we approach
product development and innovation
we always create something different and
special and unique
for our customers i noticed that you
carefully couched that answer in terms
of proprietary information
but the fact of the matter is apple has
in effect appropriated
uh euphemism for unauthorized
taking of this information to copy and
kill
competitors it's reportedly done this so
often
that it's earned a nickname with
developers
sherlocking apple and google have access
to troves of private information about
apps
on their app stores and it enables them
to
identify popular and mason apps
and then copy and kill them by
introducing those competing apps that
mimic the original
apple's former ceo steve jobs put it
the company has quote always been
shameless about stealing great ideas
end quote that seems to be the mo
of apple and there are numerous examples
of this copy and kill
strategy we've heard
about air tags which are a cop carbon
copy of tiles
item tracking products so
let me ask you mr ander do you impose
a strict firewall
does apple impose a strict firewall
between the app store
and its business strategy
senator if i understand the question
correctly we have separate teams that
manage the app store
and that are engaged in product
development strategy here at apple
yeah i understand you have separate
teams you have a barrier
between the two what we call in law
firms a chinese wall
do you have a strict prohibition
against the sharing of information
between the app store
and the people who run those businesses
senator we have controls in place uh i
would also hasten to add that
you know in terms of when you look at
the marketplace over the last 12 years
we've only introduced a handful of
applications and services during that
time
and in each and every instance there are
dozens
of alternatives available through the
app store oftentimes
more popular and more successful than
our own
uh apple service or products so
we don't copy we don't kill uh what we
do is
offer up a new choice and a new
innovation for consumers
the answer though to whether you have a
data firewall
is no that's the way i took the answer
to
my question mr white does google have a
firewall between the app store and his
business strategy
senator my understanding is we do have
data access controls in place that
govern how
data from our third-party services
are used when
when you say access control do you mean
a firewall
in other words nowhere i'm not sure
exactly what you mean by my firewall do
you have a prohibition against access
we have prohibitions uh against using
our third-party services
uh to compete directly with our first
party services senator
how long have you had and we have
internal policies that govern that
well i'm going to explore this question
in
in written questions i apologize
that my time has expired thank you madam
chairwoman
very good thank you senator blumenthal
senator holly thank you very much madam
chair thanks for holding this hearing
thanks also to senator lee
uh it is uh no secret to anybody on this
committee that i think that antitrust
enforcement
not only needs to be a top priority but
we need to make significant changes to
our anti-trust laws
in order to ensure that we are doing
everything we can to get real anti-trust
enforcement of this century let me just
come to you mr
ander i noticed since last april apple
has bought back
58 billion dollars in stock that's a big
number
uh quite a shift from from where you
were under steve jobs who used to insist
that apple
wouldn't buy back stock because it
needed to innovate it needed to retain
those profits in order to reinvest
but uh you've clearly changed position
that's fine i just want to focus on one
major source of that income it's not
innovation
it's not research and development it's
the monopoly rents
that you collect out of your app store
now i noticed that
you today have referred to the need to
to have that monopoly control over the
app store in terms of the security
rationale behind it tim cook has said
the same thing he said recently in a new
york times podcast that
apple needed to lock up the ecosystem
the ios ecosystem so it could limit
vulnerability
the thing about that that seems strange
to me is you don't seem to spend very
much money on actual
on security i mean all of the all of the
money you make on your apple tax
you don't invest very much of it into
actual security in fact
it looks to me like you didn't even
launch your bounty program where you pay
researchers to discover security
vulnerabilities on ios until 2016
when you did that you capped it you had
a hard cap on the spend
you finally raised the level somewhat in
2019
so it doesn't seem to be that big of a
priority so let me just ask you this
here's my question
will you commit will apple commit to
spending
all of the money that it raises all of
the income it raises
out of that apple tax all those monopoly
rents
will it commit to spending all of those
on security
since that's allegedly why you need to
have a monopoly in this market
uh senator i appreciate the question
we've invested
billions of dollars in securing our
our iphone our app store and all of our
products
this is a priority for us each and every
day we wake up
24 7 365 days a year
so if you look at the app store and app
review process we had a hundred thousand
submissions
each week we have a combination of ai
and human review to review all of those
we reject 40
of them because they may pose some sort
of either performance security
privacy risk uh to consumers and so this
is something we take incredibly
seriously
and if you look at the objective studies
that are out there time and time again
they find that the
iphone is the most secure platform uh in
the most secure device available on the
market
i didn't thank you for that i didn't i
don't think i heard a yes or no though
in there so let me just
try again will will you commit to
spending
if security is the reason you need to
have these this monopoly and collect
these monopoly rents which are sizable
will you commit to spending that money
all of it
on security for
uh apps the app store we're going to
continue to invest in the app store
there's a number of things that we do to
ensure that developers are able to
create their apps
there's all the tools and resources and
applications that we make available to
developers that's part of what's at
issue with our model
we also invest obviously to make sure
that our marketplace is trusted
uh and safe for consumers so there's a
number of competing
uh investments and incentives for us to
make sure that we continue
the very best experience i don't mean to
cut you off i just have limited time
that's that sounds like a no to me which
is kind of what i thought you'd say
my concern with that is just it makes it
hard for me to ignore
the major dangers to competition that
your monopoly
in the ios market opposes now you
recently announced that the smallest
developers in the app store get a redeem
will pay a reduced fee 15
it's very generous of you you announced
earlier that you take only 15
from subscription revenue after the
first year you take 30 percent
in that first year here's my question
does
apple ever cut more generous deals
to well-connected executives and other
companies you know to
to big-time companies not to the small
companies but do you ever cut more
generous deals to
to the really big companies
uh senator we do not mail a fundamental
principle since the very beginning is we
treat all developers the same
and so when we launched this store 12
years ago we took the price
which was 60 70 and took it all the way
down to 30 percent
in part because we wanted to encourage
those new small and mid-sized businesses
to enter this market and what we've seen
over the last 12 years
as we've evolved that model and we've
reduced price time and time again
because now we have a marketplace with
1.7 million apps
85 which pay nothing so we think it's
been an incredible benefit
uh to startups to small mid-sized
businesses
uh and individual entrepreneurs well i
find that answer strange because the
house judiciary antitrust subcommittee
uncovered documents from 2016 that show
that eddie q of your company negotiated
a deal directly with jeff bezos
at amazon for a special deal for prime
video
whereby apple would collect just 15 of
the revenue from customers signing up
within the amazon app
for prime video now i'm curious on on
what
basis these special terms were offered
to amazon
uh senator there was no special deal
provided solely to amazon
those negotiations led to a new program
on the app store
the premium video partner program there
are over
200 developers that have taken advantage
of this program
including amazon so there are a number
of developers it's open to all
it's another instance in which we've
reduced the price to developers to
encourage
new innovation and investment and we
made those same terms available to every
developer
so the program is the established
program for premium subscription video
entertainment
providers if i'm correct what happened
here for those who are keeping score at
home is that
years later when it was discovered that
amazon had that apple rather had given
amazon a special deal apple comes back
and says oh no we've had a program it's
established
it's this program for premium
subscription video entertainment
providers that's a mouthful of course
premium subscription video entertainment
providers means
it wasn't by definition open to
everybody you know this is not the first
time that apple has has done this the
house antitrust subcommittee revealed
that apple granted
baidu that's a chinese company a fast
track through the app review process and
even assigned two employees
to give baidu concierge service you've
also given netflix
special deals that other smaller
developers like appae
didn't get for example it looks like to
me here's my here's my point it looks
like to me
that what you've done is is you've been
willing to cut special deals
with other major companies who already
have significant market power
and have significant market share could
use it to squeeze you but for smaller
competitors
who are trying to get into the market
for those guys and gals
there you really put the squeeze on them
isn't that accurate
uh respectfully senator it is not uh we
have operated a store for the last 12
years
that has continually looked for ways to
encourage small and independent
businesses
to grow and develop on the app store
there is program after program that
we've launched
we feature these apps on our app store
in terms of
small and innovative applications we
launched the small
mid-size business program last year
which reduced the commission
uh for small businesses that were
subject to the commission
so we're going to continue to find ways
to invest
to make it possible for everyone to
create on the app store
well my time has expired i look forward
to
pursuing some additional questions with
you and uh for the other witnesses
in writing but i'll just note in closing
that what it it looks like to me
the pattern here is that apple is happy
to jerry-rig the rules
and is happy to cut special side deals
and is happy to try and turn away
uh keep big-time competitors from
cutting into your market make special
deals with them while putting the
squeeze and the lid on small competitors
all in service of keeping this gravy
train of monopoly rinse
flowing that's a big problem
and it's one i think that it's time that
we addressed and that's one of the
reasons i'm glad we've had this hearing
today
thank you madam chair thank you very
much senator holly
next senator ossoff
thank you madam chair thank you to the
panel mr white mr ander
senator hawley noted that you've
consistently argued
a justification for the market power you
exercise here is your ability
to regulate the safety and security and
protection for consumers
of apps that are sold on your platforms
one of the things that i think is most
distressing
is that it's trivially easy to find apps
on
both of your platforms which
are scams which are promoted
by in some cases hundreds or thousands
of obviously
fake positive reviews and which
trap users in billing arrangements
that are expensive punitive
marketed and it's very difficult to
unsubscribe from some of these monthly
billing arrangements
so what steps are you taking
to end the proliferation of scam apps on
your platforms
when you state publicly repeatedly
that the value of your platforms is in
consumer protection
safety and security of the consumer and
why do we rely upon open source
reporting and journalists to find
all of these apps that are trivially
easy to identify as scams
mr ander go ahead please sure thank you
senator
uh we've invested tens of millions
hundreds of millions of dollars
in hardening and improving the security
literally billions of dollars over the
years
unfortunately security and fraud is a
cat and mouse game any retailer will
tell you that
and so we're constantly working to
improve
and we do that in a variety of ways
internally we're investing in more
resources more technologies more tools
to make sure that we can catch these
wrong doors
we reject thousands tens of thousands of
apps
each year that pose a risk to our
consumers
whether it's from the perspective of
security or from fraud
we also rely on our external community
there are a number of stakeholders who
will raise issues and this is important
you know unfortunately no one is perfect
but i think what we've shown over and
over again that we do a better job
than others i think one of the real
risks of
opening up uh the iphone to
side loading or third-party app stores
is that this problem will only multiply
if we look at other app stores out there
if we look at other distribution
platforms
it scares us mr endear mr ander thank
you i appreciate the response and i want
to talk about the side loading question
in a moment but let me just ask you this
when again there is so much reporting
in tech press there are independent
researchers who
find many of these scam apps on your
platform
sometimes they hook people into paying
10 bucks a week or 10 bucks a month
recurring subscriptions for meaningless
services
apple is making a cut
on those abusive billing practices are
you not
uh respectfully senator i don't believe
that's the case
if we find fraud if we find a problem
we're able to rectify that very quickly
and we do each and every day
so if if you if you identify an app mr
ander that
is obviously engaged in scan billing
practices
does apple refund all of apple's
revenues
derived from those scam billing
practices to the consumer
uh senator that's my understanding
there's obviously a dedicated team
here at apple who works this each and
every day
but my understanding is that we work
hard to make sure that the customer
is in a whole position that's our focus
at the end of the day
if we lose the trust of our customers
that's going to hurt us
mr white another question about consumer
safety privacy and security
certain apps available through google's
platform as well as apple's platform
have included software development kits
sdks which send user location data to
third parties often location
data brokers there's a massive market
for this data
governments buy it corporations buy it
spies buy it
in one prominent example a location data
company called x mode
sold consumer data to defense
contractors derived from its sdk
on products sold on both the apple and
google stores
both companies announced they'd banned
the products but researchers continue to
find the xmode sdk
mr white and hundreds of android apps
even after the ban
are any x mode sdks still present on
apps sold
on google's store and what steps are you
taking to protect your users
from the sale of location data to data
brokers
thank you mr uh osap it's a really good
question
and the security issue as mr anders said
it really is a difficult one and one we
have to invest in
heavily to stay in front of and that's
why on
every android device that has google
services we have we require that those
devices have google play protect
it's our security monitoring uh service
which scans 100 billion app installs
every day
and just in 2019 google play protect
removed 1.9 billion instances of malware
and other security vulnerabilities from
non-google play sources
just to give you a sense of the scale at
which we're trying to attack but to be
clear mr white and just
given my limited time i'm referring to
sdks which
perhaps should be classified as malware
but are not currently classified as
malware
do you agree that the data broker market
is exploitive
and abusive and that most of your users
have no idea
how much information is flowing to these
data brokers
one of the things senator that we we
take very seriously is our
responsibility to keep the users who
come to google play for a safe and
enjoyable experience
to keep them safe and that's why we have
policies in place
and if developers violate those policies
we review
every app that's submitted to the google
play store whether it's a new submission
or an update to an existing app before
it's published
uh and as mr endear said similarly we
have that that's a combination of
human review and automated tools mr
white
will you kindly will you please provide
to this committee
within 30 days an assessment of whether
any x-mode
sdk malware or any other x-mode sdk
technology remains on apps sold on the
google store
yes senator happy to look into that and
follow up with your office with more
details there
and i'd like you to commit to providing
that information not just to looking
into it please
sounds good senator will do thank you so
much finally
uh mr cooper
thank you for joining us today mobile
apps collect use and store a massive
array of sensitive personal data
do you believe we need legislation that
would ensure that the privacy policies
provided by app developers
and app stores disclose
in plain english that's decipherable
to everyone all data collection
practices
data storage practices and third parties
to whom such data might be sold
yes yeah that was that was in fact the
thrust of my of the second half of my
recommendations
because the demand side it turns out is
as important as a supply side
and if you liberate these folks they
won't get any place if the consumer
doesn't have sovereignty so um the idea
of
open fair actionable
information provided to consumers true
consumer choice
is absolutely critical the interesting
thing here is that
this is one area in particular there may
be others
where it may not be the antitrust
authorities
who you want to do that because it's not
the kind of thing they do
they don't engage in behavioral
regulation
they actually avoid it as best they can
so
this is one area where you really need
standalone legislation and we need to
have a good conversation about
who the regulator should be we may not
have any in our society we may have to
create a new office
we we can look around but there's no
doubt that if you don't
fix the demand side and the flow of
information and give consumers back
their sovereignty
which they have lost to these platforms
you will not get very far towards
promoting competition
thank you dr cooper thank you madam
chair okay thank you very much
uh senator assaf good job before i turn
to
senator blackburn just some submissions
for the record
from john burgmeyer charlotte slayman
and
alex petros at petros at public
knowledge
from morgan reed at the app association
from bruce gustafson and sarah richard
at developers alliance
from megan de muzzio at the coalition
for app fairness
from tech freedom from arthur sydney of
the computer and communications we must
have a good hearing
center leave this from arthur sydney of
the computer and communications industry
association
and from professor michael jack obidi
jack obedies of the london school of
business
i seek unanimous consent to enter these
submissions into the record
without objection senator blackburn
thank you
madam chairman and yes indeed it is a
good hearing and i think that
the witnesses see this is an area where
there is a good bit of
agreement and uh picking up where
senator
ossoff left off you know
there is frustration with some of the
big tech
providers when it comes to the issue of
privacy and security and dr
cooper i appreciate your remarks one of
the questions we ask is who owns the
virtual you
who owns the virtual you which is you
and your presence
on line and uh to mr white
from google we are fully aware
that you collect this information and
then you monetize this information
and so the question is why should we
trust that google will not
use this information to further entrench
this data monopoly that they have
going so um mr white
why should we trust google to not
monetize
this information and to benefit from it
and will google commit since you didn't
want to answer
senator ossoff's question i'll pose it
to you a different way
will google commit will you commit in
writing
that you are not going to use any
of this consumer data information to
inform
your other business lines and to not
collect or store
any information other than that that is
necessary to facilitate the transaction
that is taking place on your system so
mr white
will you commit to that that you're not
going to capture and hold
and utilize and monetize this
information
that you're going to let consumers own
their presence online are you ready to
make that commitment to us
thank you senator blackburn for the
question um to your point
around why should consumers trust us
that that is
the core thrust of our business model
we're an information company mr white
that is
really not the question i'm asking for
your commitment
you ready to give it and senator what
what we do is we try to provide
users with transparency security and
control
we give them access to the data that's
uh being collected and we give them the
controls
they can decide you're skirting the
question so i'll reclaim my time
let me go over to apple apple seems to
have two operating standards there's one
for doing business in america there's a
second standard
for appeasing the communist chinese
apple
kicked fortnight and i'm aware of
fortnite i have two grandsons that are
11 and 12
and i've watched them play fortnite well
apple decided to kick
fortnite out of the app store over a
feast dispute but it lets
tick-tock stay on despite violating
privacy rules and apple
will pull hong kong pro-democracy apps
from its store
when the communist party demands
that it pull it but then it won't will
not
cooperate with the fbi to catch
terrorists in america
and madam chairman there's an excellent
article on apple's willingness to bend
the knee to china in the new york post
it is called is your iphone worth
china's
tyranny and i would ask your permission
to insert that into the record
without objection it's on the record
thank you there's the tim cook run apple
which turns a blind eye to communist
china's
human rights abuses in tibet and
xinjiang then there's the apple of hong
kong
run by jimmy ly who is willing to go to
jail
for a publication that fights for
democracy
and it is sad to see the apple of the
west
speak up against injustice in america
yet stay silent when it comes to china's
atrocities
and the genocide they are carrying out
against
the uyghur so this month apple is
finally rolling out
new privacy policies that claim to
empower
users and stop unwanted location
tracking and i'm concerned that apple's
privacy by design as it's called cannot
coexist with turning a blind eye toward
beijing's behaviors
last year forbes reported that apple
caught tick tock
spying on users using the clipboard
feature
even now tick-tock is plotting ways to
get around apple's new privacy policies
yet take talk remains available to
download
in the app store putting iphone users
privacy at risk if apple is imposing
30 for safety and security does that
mean
apple is also responsible for all costs
related to breaches of safety and
security
on iphones
waiting for an answer thank you senator
uh we take privacy incredibly seriously
seriously here at apple uh we've
embedded technologies and features over
the last 25 years to ensure that all of
our products
respect your security and respect your
privacy that guides our own products
that also is increasingly guiding our
third-party
developers and partners to make sure
that your information
you know understand who has access to it
and you have control
over it that's true here in the united
states in china and around the world
okay so um all right
but still you are charging
30 for safety and security
so when breaches occur which is my
question
are you responsible for all costs
related to breaches of safety and
security i was not asking
if you took it seriously i was asking
for
your actions so you assume
all of those costs and then let me
continue
if let me ask you this are you telling
congress
and the world writ large that
you are charging this massive sum
because this work
is very difficult and
that you do it well that you have
extraordinary security measures and if
that's the case
why should you get all the money but not
take
any of the responsibility for
the breaches of safety and security on
iphones and ipads
senator we've thrown open the gates of
the iphone to third-party development
uh and from the very beginning we've had
a model to support that
in terms of charging a commission for
digital goods and services
that supports all the technology
resources
and other things that we pour into our
developer program
and to build the app store part of that
is security and privacy
absolutely and it's something we'll
continue to invest in
and continue to work on we now have a
marketplace in which we have 1.7 million
apps
84 of them pay nothing we are working
tirelessly to create the best possible
experience for both our customers and
developers okay i am running out of time
but thank you for the answer uh mr sein
i have a question to you that will
relate to that
i will submit it to you uh for asking
and ask him now oh okay thank you uh let
me ask you
with match you all have an app so
how do apple and google use
safety as a pretext for controlling what
apps can or can't do in the app store
and how do you see them selectively
applying standards to disfavored
apps because i can't get a straight
answer from
either of them and i've been listening
to the hearing in my office
and i have heard a lot of hot air
and generalities and not a lot of
specifics
yes senator the reality for us is we
don't see
a lot in terms of safety that they're
talking about
that they provide to us again as we
mentioned they don't even do the
basic which you would think is limiting
underage users from downloading our apps
when they know that those user
users are under age we've actually seen
them as i mentioned in taiwan block our
app because we wanted to do id
verification
they've blocked other versions of our
app because we wanted to do multi-factor
authentication telling us
that it was inappropriate for us to
mandate two forms of
identification in order to make sure
that someone could access our app
because we wanted to make sure it was
the right person so when
apple talks about the need for safety
security etc
you know the reality is it was really
about safety security etc
in-app payment would be applied to every
app on the platform not just fifteen
percent
because we all have users thank you for
the clarification mr gutierrez i will
come
to you for a question written i spoke to
the house of lords in
the uk yesterday on a couple of things
so i'll just send those to you in
writing and
madam chairman you were generous with
the time i think this shows exactly why
we need to move forward with privacy
data security
anti-trust and section 230 reforms in
order to provide
protection for consumers in the virtual
space excellent
thank you very much senator blackburn
senator lee
thank you madam chair uh when senator
blackburn referred to the house of lords
a minute ago i
flinched a little bit because usually
that's used as a denigrating reference
to the senate but uh i know you were
talking about the actual house of lords
uh mr gutierrez let's let's start with
you in this round um
a recent filing in the in the epic epic
versus apple case um
contains some quotes uh some quoted
discussions with
philip shoemaker apple's director
of app store review from 2009
until 2016. shoemaker said that
apple had used the app store uh quote as
a weapon against competitors close quote
and uh and has rejected or
delayed competing apps on protectual
grounds
um he further explained that although in
theory
an ios developer that's unhappy
uh with apple could simply leave the ios
platform
and perhaps write only for android
and and compete only in that space
um so although they they say that uh
perhaps
most most app developers don't
considering
uh don't consider taking that step
and therefore don't consider abandoning
ios to be
a viable realistic option so my question
to you is
if if developers can't leave
if they feel that's not a viable option
even if they're being
abused or mistreated um
how would an operating system ever feel
the need to change why would they change
if they've got a captive group of people
who
have no place else to go or who can't go
senator the reality is they want they
won't do it out of their own
initiative they have to be forced to
change
and that is why we were the first
company to actually publicly
you know have the courage to come out
and speak about these things
and then what's happened since then is
this debate has really
blossom this debate has really happened
across both sides of the atlantic
and now you see companies come in front
of you
a coalition that we helped found now has
55 members and continues to grow and it
is
only through companies speaking out
about the real implications of their
actions
and you know legislators and government
agencies and enforcement agencies
looking into these issues
that they're ever going to change
otherwise they will continue to apply to
this
superficial pretext and continue to
behave
exactly in the same way that they have
in the past
okay something you just said um
maybe remember a question asked by
senator klobuchar
to another witness earlier in the
hearing um
when you talk about having the courage
to talk about it
um as a result of testifying today did
you
feel fearful of retribution
well i because we have a long history of
engaging with apple i think they know
better than to call us on the eve
of our appearance here but i over the
years i can tell you right off the top
of my head
of at least four clear examples of
threats and retaliation
that we face with them from the very
existential threat of being removed
from the app store because we had
decided not to implement the payment
system going forward to the clear
statement to us that our app
even though at the time was a top
grossing app on the app
it would never be promoted on the app
store
or received any marketing because we
were
a competitor to changes unilateral
changes to the rules
that retroactively outlawed things that
we did
in our products to having to wait some
time months
sometimes months for our app updates to
be approved
even though they contain bug fixes
and vulnerability fixes as well as a
number of other things
they they they basically thrown the book
at us
in a number of ways to make it hard for
us to continue to sustain our
our uh our decision to speak up thank
you
senator lee yeah let me make
is to have a department of justice they
believe
that will carry their listen to their
complaints and carry them forward
and that's exactly what your job is is
to create that current department of
justice
because otherwise they're naked when
they have a department of justice
they can tell you what the problem is
they can say
that's why it's
mr ander um
apple frequently cites the need to
protect users privacy and
security now these are laudable goals
uh in fact um you know i'm
i'm an apple customer uh
for that reason and and and and many
others uh
and i appreciate apple's
sincere commitment not to sell my data
and and to protect my privacy but how
can competitors
and customers and legislators
and others be sure that security and
privacy
aren't being used as a pretext
to exclude competition as alleged by mr
shoemaker and the question i asked a
moment ago to mr gutierrez
for example other documents in the epic
litigation that i
referenced revealed that apple's human
review process
typically took 13 minutes per app
13 minutes for each app and
that the lead engineer responsible for
detecting fraud and abuse in the app
store
analogized the review process to
bringing
a plastic butter knife to a gunfight
meanwhile it seems like apps that
present
uh a potential competitive a threat a
sort of threat to apple are often
delayed
or blocked or disadvantaged
in other cases um apps that don't
present those
but uh perhaps offer a differing
viewpoint
i'm referring here to the parlor uh
suffer a different sort of fake but
anyway back to the
back to the competing space and how can
we
ensure that your privacy and security
protections
are in fact narrowly tailored to help
consumers while minimizing the impact on
competition and that that
those concerns aren't being used to
shoehorn in
anti-competitive behavior
senator i appreciate the question i
think what we have is
a 12-year track record that we can look
back upon
and so what we have done consistently
year after year day after day
is think about how we can harden and
secure our devices to make them the most
secure in the marketplace as study after
study is found
and introduce new features to give you
the power
and the information you need to make to
decide whether you're going to share
your information or not
with uh with a particular developer
now in terms of what that track record
also shows is over that 12
years the app store and everything that
we've made available
uh to developers has unlocked a
tremendous amount of competition
so if you look at our apps and there's
just a handful of them
they're a drop in the bucket of this
ocean of 1.7 million apps
and in each and every category you're
going to see an
alternative like spotify or someone else
who is doing better than our service
there is no advantage uh seen
in the market you know from my
perspective and you know i've been
practicing this area for 20 years
i always look to the market for answers
and so i look to see like
what is happening and when we look at
see what's happening we see that
competitors are not just doing well
on iphone they're thriving no no wait a
minute is is that what you were doing
when you got publishers to fix the
prices of ebooks
is that the track record you're
referring to sir
uh senator no i am not that is a a
different business in terms of uh
selling ebooks
it's a different business yeah but it
was anti-competitive
uh and you're asking us to take your
word for it here and we've got witnesses
here telling us
that they're um that they're scared that
they're intimidated
what's your response to that senator
i would again look at our 12-year track
record so if you look at spotify
they've been downloaded from the app
store nearly a half a billion times
we have processed dozens hundreds of
updates for them over the years
they built the market leading position
in digital music
streaming if you look at tinder and all
the other brands
acquired over the years they have been
downloaded hundreds of millions of times
and we processed
thousands of updates and so if you judge
us by our track record you'll see that
we've not just uh not engaged in this
kind of bad activity we've been
supporting these businesses
and we're going to continue to going
forward there's no evidence of
retaliation
when you got publishers to fix the
prices of ebooks was that not part of
your app store business
uh senator no it was no it was not it
was part of our
ibooks business our ibook store
and again in that case we are judged by
the evidence
we may disagree with the outcomes but we
were judged by the evidence
i'm asked all i'm saying is you can look
at the evidence of the app store of the
last 12 years
and see that has created this incredible
economic it's still a store
it's still a store on ios devices
yes it is senator and it's been a store
for nearly 12 years with the same basic
business model
and all we've done time and time again
is reduce prices and introduce
flexibility
for developers to create their their
amazing applications for our customers
um madam chair i see them dangerously
over time i apologize
that's okay do you have any more you're
good it's fine
okay very good all right i have uh i
have a few more questions here and then
we'll
uh finish up so uh mr ander you've
argued in the past uh in actually in
testimony before the arizona
house of representatives and in your
written testimony that the 30
commission is not just a payment
processing fee
but it also reflects as many of the
other senators
discussed with you the secure app
environment created by apple and the
fact that the app store is like a studio
for developers
providing developer applications and
apis
to help them build apps um so
first of all do
i guess my question is similar to what
you've heard before
if that was the case it seems like all
developers benefit from the secure apple
environment and that all developers who
roll in the in
apple developer program for ninety nine
dollars get access to app store
developer tools
what benefits in addition to payment
processing to the developers
who must pay the in-app purchase
commission
get it sounds like all they get is
payment processing is an inflated price
i'm just trying to figure out the
difference and you've had a discussion
of course with
senator lee about the difference between
dating and getting a ride which was
fascinating
when i will never forget you've had a
discussion with senator holly
um about you know why don't you just
have the security fee
charged or there's just no way this can
cost
30 percent of the of what they bring in
the security piece of it so my question
is again what benefits in addition to
payment processing
do the developers who must pay the
in-app purchase commission get
sure senator i appreciate the question
the model that we introduced along with
opening up the iphone to third-party
development uh 12 years ago was simple
we said hey if you're going to sell a
digital good or service you're going to
be subject to the commission
that supports all the investments and
all the things we've done
in terms of continuing to open up the
iphone and additional features and
technologies we've gone from
10 000 apis to 250 000 we have launched
frameworks and resources and software
to make it incredibly easy for a
developer to build an app
we have built a store that's now in 175
different countries
with unique storefronts we have an
editorial team that features
different applications and different
developers uh and so there's an
incredible amount of investment that we
make into the app store
and the technology platform that
supports the store
uh and we recuperate that we we drive
that from the
the commission structure uh and we think
that's it's been a fair deal and it's
proven out
uh over the last 12 years in the form of
we've got 1.7 million apps
we've got incredible rich array of
content available to our consumers
so we see this as a business that's been
great for development wouldn't it
wouldn't it be better for consumers if
you were
if these guys were able to tell them
that they could get cheaper rates
somewhere else well senator i
absolutely agree and they all do uh
spotify
they can they can spotify could say hey
you can get a cheaper
uh cheaper rate on our website can they
say that
on your app so to be clear
senator spotify can do that through one
of its more than 8 000 partnerships
uh what it does in our app and what we
say in our app much like
what verizon would say to apple if we
said hey we want to come into the
verizon store and put a sign up that
says
go buy our iphone down the street uh at
the apple store they're not going to
allow us to do that
no retailer is going to allow us to do
that
there's a difference with fundamentals
okay i think there's a difference maybe
mr
gutierrez you want to respond with us
that analogy with where they are when
they're depending on you for this app
store i
i do and you know this is this is
highlighting a really important point
you know apple takes the position that
our users
are their users that they own the
customer relationship
they're injecting themselves in the
middle of the relationship and they
believe that they can control
our communications with them our offers
to them the promotions and benefits
that we give them and that is the heart
of the problem here
which is this is a model where basically
a handful of global gatekeeper platforms
can't claim that they
own the user relationship of all the
users of
all the apps that are offered on the on
the mobile platforms
that is the path that this approach is
leading to
which is why it is so important that
these issues are addressed
yes uh dr cooper i know you haven't
gotten too many questions
but you didn't get a call last night not
to testify so
i mean that's not what they said they
might not they didn't say that to
match.com but they questioned their
earnings statement but even better you
didn't get a question like that right
so um i guess i want to know from your
perspective
as uh someone who uh advocates on
consumers behalf
so this issue that we're just talking
about with apple and with spotify which
is really an issue for everyone that
gets
that can't advertise that
you can get cheaper rates uh for their
consumers how does that affect consumers
and how does the fee two separate things
the ban on telling them that
they can get cheaper rates somewhere and
then the fee
look if these folks could compete on a
level playing field
it would have a benefit that has been
missed here
that would put tremendous competitive
pressure on the platforms
and they would look out in the world say
holy mackerel we could lose all these
customers
to someone else who's treating them
fairly and so that would put tremendous
pressure on the platform
the second thing that could happen is
that these folks could get together and
say you know what
we've got enough users to build our own
platform and
new entry that was the logic of the
microsoft case
which in fact if you go down the list of
abuses you started with
is identical to the microsoft case how
it is for 20 years we have not
won the court cases and we have them now
we it's amazing it is amazing how much
they've done the same dirty old business
practices
so and those hurt consumers we learned
that a long time ago
our best protection is real competition
and this is a space in which we don't
have exactly
i bet you've been waiting to say that dr
cooper behind your mask
okay so um the house antitrust
uh subcommittee uh digital markets
report cited estimates that apple makes
between
15 and 18 billion dollars a year on the
app store
uh mr ander but according to philip
shoemaker apple's former director of app
review for the app store
it costs less than 100 million a year to
run the app store
that sounds like an incredibly
profitable business and frankie
you know as was noted by several of my
colleagues those look like monopoly
profits
how does apple justify the 30 commission
fee rate when the cost of running the
app store is so much lower than the
revenues the company
generates from the app store
senator i appreciate the question as
i've mentioned
apple's invested significant sums in
technologies
resources tools to allow developers to
build their apps far in excess of this
hundred million dollar figure okay so
then what is the correct number
uh senator i don't have the the exact
figure i know it's more than a hundred
billion dollars that we've invested
in ios and you know how much revenue
it generated last year i mean it's
relevant because we're talking here
about a monopoly situation
senator understood uh you know when we
look at the app store it's not a
separate standalone business for us
it's an integrated feature of our
devices
and so we don't have a separate profit
and loss statement
for the app store what we do know is
that the economic opportunity has been
studied and assessed
and we know that developers are creating
apps
you know whether it's mobile advertising
or selling physical goods or digital
goods and content
that's generated more than 500 billion
dollars i think you mentioned this in
your your opening statement
uh so there's an incredible economic
opportunity that's been created uh for
developers on a very small percentage of
those sales
uh do we love you a commission okay but
so you have no numbers
uh which i'm sure exists we'll try
asking you in writing
but i have no choice but to go with the
house numbers because
there is no other number on the table
and that it's a hundred million dollars
a year to run the app store and that you
make 15 to 18
billion dollars so mr white
how much does it cost google to run the
play store and how much
revenue did it generate in the last full
year
senator i don't have those uh exact
numbers but happy to follow up with you
with your team on that
what i can say though is um with the
android ecosystem
the amount of competition and choice
that that has brought to the mobile
landscape
how it's brought down the cost of mobile
devices as i said in my opening
statement
you can get an android phone now for
less than 100 bucks and then you're
opening
comments you talked about accessibility
why it's important for people to have
access to mobile devices and we think
that's what android has actually brought
to this landscape and
almost 2 million american jobs that have
been created by uh this ecosystem
okay um and i i believe and i said very
clearly at the beginning that i
i don't challenge the success i'm proud
that we've developed these innovations
in america but you have to keep
rejuvenating capitalism you have to keep
allowing new people to come up with new
ideas and i'm not going to go beyond
this issue but i think
well maybe i will for 30 seconds but i
think when you look at some of these
purchases of facebook of instagram and
whatsapp and what's happened
that and then you look at all the
problems we've had
in terms of privacy and other things
that you're literally stifling
this is not about you of course but in
general
the tech companies are stifling some of
the new developments we could see
um for privacy and other things by um
by how this has all gone down and then
you have on top of that
um the issues for consumers and
i guess do you think uh dr cooper
listening to those numbers i just read
out which are the only ones available to
us
do you think that these companies are
operating in a competitive market apple
and google
actually there are actually there are
other numbers which
are in one of the reports we will file
with the committee i
looked at the learner index for these
for for
for these two companies and it is way
above the national average
they are overcharging consumers for
their products and earning
excess profits and these two companies
in particular
there are other digital companies that
were much lower and it turned
out that they exist in marketplaces
where they face much more competition
the absence of competition in that
document and i will call
your staff's attention to it is
demonstrated to me
that we are being overcharged and our
prices could be lower
and and you're not none of the companies
here before us
uh um are saying that this in person
here
are saying that this should be free
right you're just
questioning the amount of the charges
there should be a normal rate of profit
on that line of business
and as you've heard and you suggested
there is not
and the only way they can keep that is
if they exercise their market power
and lock consumers out okay
um another related issue
uh mr gutierrez some developers have
raised concerns about app store
operators preferencing their own
apps in app stores searches so that
their apps show up at the top of the
search results i remember a long time
ago
this issue raised in a different context
by senator lee
you share this concern yes this is just
another manifestation of the
complete control that they that they
have and the fact that the decision on
who gets promoted who gets discoverable
is really
completely manipulated to help apple's
um own services so
this makes it really clear we've heard
apple say a number of times
about all the value that they brought to
these apps including
some of the services that are
represented here the reality senator
is that spotify and i i can say the same
thing probably for match
and for tile we are not successful
because
of what apple has done we have been
successful despite
apple's interference and we would have
been much more successful
but for their anti-competitive behavior
okay um
so mr white what are the factors google
uses to display
app results when a consumer searches for
something in the play store does it
preference google own apps in the play
store has it ever done so
absolutely not senator we're an
information company and
our core business model depends on users
trusting us to provide accurate unbiased
information and so we don't preference
our first party services over our
third-party services
in the google play store we want when
users come to the play store searching
for their favorite apps or games
for them to find the most relevant
information okay mr ander i've seen news
reports that apple has a 42-factor
algorithm for how it displays app
results when a consumer searches for
something
is that correct and which factors weigh
most heavily in your algorithm does
apple preference apple owned apps in the
app store searches has it ever done so
senator i'm not intimately familiar with
our search algorithm in the app store
but i do know that we do not
favor our own applications or services
in the search functionality and again i
think if you look at the experience
uh over the last 12 years we have over
half a billion users who have found and
downloaded
spotify during that time same is true
for a whole host of other companies that
compete with us
so the objective evidence is hey
consumers are finding what they were
looking for
um so no we do not favor ourselves in
search this guy would do those answers
give you comfort
no they do not why not
because
we're hearing over and over things that
don't that aren't consistent with our
experience for instance
this more uh earlier today uh mr anders
said that
um we couldn't talk about the mfi
agreement because they were
in negotiations um with other developers
regarding that agreement
um but we were told that
basically we could not negotiate that
agreement um
and that that agreement we had to sign
as is and in fact that they're not going
to give us
any more information about this um
program unless we actually sign it so
it's
things like that that make me question
some of the um statements
um mr ander analysis of both of you i
guess
mr white a number of apps related to
this a number of app developers have
complained about a lack of
transparency regarding application of
apples in google's respective app store
rules and policies
and they have expressed frustration
about often not knowing why an
app or an app update has been rejected
for each app or update that is rejected
or removed from the app store by apple
mr ander will apple commit to providing
the developer of the app
with a written explanation of why the
app or update was removed or rejected
in a timely manner including citations
to the applicable
apple rules or policies under which the
decision was made
will you do that senator we we do that
today
uh we constantly we have guidelines we
have for 12 years
we are in constant engagement and
discussion with developers
as i mentioned we get 100 000
submissions each week we have to reject
40
of those whether it's for performance
safety security or some other reason
in each and every instance we try to
communicate what the issues are
uh and we talk to thousands of
developers
uh each and every week and
google answers on that yeah thank you
senator very good question uh very
similarly that's that's generally our
practice today i will say one caveat to
that is
if there is a serious security violation
we may remove that app more quickly just
to make sure we're protecting our users
and and their devices
as i said the google play protect uh
monitoring program
scans 100 billion apps every day right
and so if there is a major security
violation we will take that app off of
the play store very quickly
and then communicate with the developer
on what the violation may have been
okay whenever we do take enforcement
actions like that
we do give our developer partners um
avenues for redress
they can appeal those decisions and
those they can have those decisions
reviewed
uh again and so we make sure that our
developers are in constant communication
on how they can be in compliance with
those publicly stated policies
anyone anything on this want to respond
mr gutierrez
senator our our experience may
illustrate a little bit of how this
this application of these rules actually
happened in practice
it happened to us multiple times when we
decided to take iap down
after apple launched the competing
service at a price below
hours uh we complied with the rules as
they existed at the time which basically
said we couldn't have
a buy button or a link to a payment
mechanism
so we decided okay we'll take that it
won't be part of that
apple then came back and they said it
isn't just
that we couldn't have a buy button in
our app
if we didn't have iap we couldn't even
email our users to tell them
about a way to upgrade we couldn't
mention in the app that they could get a
premium
app we couldn't tell them that they were
discounts or
promotional plans that they could sign
on and then what happened is
the month after we did that after they
had
engaged in this extensive expansive
interpretation
that wasn't supported by the rules they
changed the rules
to retroactively support the
interpretation that they had started
applying in our case that is what total
control
of their ecosystem means in the case of
apple okay
mr sein and then i have one more
question to you mr simon and i'm almost
on our experience has been similar to mr
gutierrez i mean we've had situations
and it's not really that they don't tell
you which rule you violated
they don't tell you how you violated
that room or that rule or how to fix it
and that's the problem we had an app one
of our tinder builds that actually
had a very important safety feature for
our lgbtq plus community
where it would actually inform users
when they were in a country where they
might be at risk for
exposing their gender identity or
otherwise
that sat in the app store review process
for two months because
apple had said that we were violating a
new policy or they said the spirit
of the policy and couldn't tell us
expressly how we needed to solve it
in order to get that launched we had to
go all the way up to talking to the
chief
executives through our chief executive
at iac at the time in order to
actually get that app unblocked two
months later
well okay so you know just to kind of
pull this out from the
um trees to the forest here so
and i think mr sein i'll do this with
you here so
um i think one of the things that people
think they hear all this
and they think well why don't you just
sell it on your website then you know
why do you need these guys you know if
if there's if they're doing this to you
why can't you just go and compete on the
web on your own
could you answer that yeah like i said
at the beginning of my testimony
they have essentially taken the internet
and moved it into the app stores
and so they've set up their gateways
they've set up their toll booths you got
to pay the toll
if you're a digital good in service they
give everybody else access onto the
freeway and what we're saying is
why isn't the freeway the same for
everyone and why isn't everybody
paying the same thing as they're
traveling down the freeway and we've
never gotten a good answer to that
senator
and so to me when i hear all this i
think okay
our laws are exactly the same that they
were basically our competitive policy
laws our antitrust laws even our privacy
laws on the federal basis
are the same from back when whenever it
was and whoever did it we're not going
to get into that
the internet started um and uh that in
fact we've seen this major
change a major ecosystem change and
we're just not as sophisticated
as these um biggest companies world has
ever seen
who we're very proud of in many ways um
but
that are that are basically using that
system and so that
leads a number of us up here to say we
need to get changes and the first thing
is
uh we need to have the agencies be as
sophisticated as they can
which is why uh senator grassley and i
have the proposal
something we can do immediately the
appropriations process is more at the
end of the year
to be able to change the fees for mega
merges across the board not just tech
so that we can get more money to the ftc
and to
the um to the doj antitrust and by the
way that was supported by the trump
administration just like these lawsuits
were
actually brought by the trump
administration which i have commended
i'm making delrahim over at doj and i
trust and
former um former chair of the ftc simon
for doing
and are now being continued uh by uh the
democratic administration which is how
some of these
sexual suits as you know dr cooper uh
have gone
in the past dude they've they've bridged
administrations
and so we think that we need to get
funding uh to really
play them out like they should and the
second thing we could look at
in addition to my bill which i'm not
going to go on it since it is 5
20 p.m on the competition in antitrust
law enforcement reform act
uh which ups the um standards on
exclusionary conduct and would really
help us adapt to the world where and i
can't even call it a new world we've
been in it for quite a while and we
haven't done anything about it
but the other thing we could do i know
state lawmakers in arizona massachusetts
north dakota which isn't exactly a you
know radical state i was just over there
with senator hogan and
the republican governor on a water
project but i mean they're looking at
this
my home state of minnesota are looking
at legislation
on a state-by-state basis to regulate
app stores
and some of you have been involved in
these conversation
uh in your opinion should we consider
legislation on the federal basis
uh to regulate app stores and why
i 100 agree that that would be the right
course of action the reality is as i
said in my opening statement
this mandatory in-app payment structure
the way they have this set up that is
the lifeblood of their monopoly it is
their lifeblood to get the data from the
users it is their lifeblood
to fund all these excess profits they're
getting it is their lifeblood to be able
to
identify what competing apps are and who
their users are how much they pay when
they pay
everything and if you cut that off and
the reason they're fighting so hard to
defend it the reason they went in and
hired every lobbyist in the state of
arizona to defeat
it probably not everyone everyone but
the one we hired
the reality is they are fighting so hard
because it is core
to the maintenance of their monopoly
okay anyone else want to
take that um senator i
i would just add that in addition to the
the uh
um appropriations process that you
mentioned and in addition to the bill
we actually the broad bill that you have
proposed
we actually think it is important to
pair that with more
specific legislation on app store
uh issues the way that some of the
states are taking this legislate the
legislation we think this is an action
that's important
for federal uh preemption these markets
are
not only national they're global these
decisions that are made in
cupertino are decisions that affect our
business and indonesia
and all over the world so this is a
space in which
specific legislation on the app store
issues
would be very welcome and very
beneficial and dr cooper
senator as soon as you get a bunch of
states considering this legislation
these guys will come running to you said
you got to give me federal legislation
i've experienced this before in other
contexts yes but
yes that's that they'll they'll want it
and they figure they have a better
chance to negotiate with you
than the individuals you mean this
subcommittee i don't know about it well
this
this this is the place remarkable
bipartisan this is the place to fix
the key things about the anti-trump no
no i i know and this is the place where
we should fix them yeah
okay um ms daru i just wanted to
reiterate what mr gutierrez said about
having a specific app store bill
just because the mobile
mobile phones are the gateway to so many
aspects of our lives
banking news dating
music health fitness and
clearly there are abuses that have been
exposed today
and in the house report that need to be
addressed
and we're concerned that if we wait
for sweeping legislation
or legislation that may need to be hold
out in the courts
over several years to understand what
the impact is
to the mobile ecosystem um we could have
more reparable damage done to
competition in
innovation in america i do want to
commend
um you and your bill um
because it is a great step in the right
direction we
absolutely need um strong prohibitions
against
exclusionary behavior and discriminatory
behavior but
um would just respectfully request that
um
some consideration be given to an app
store right
i mean i you know everything we're
looking at the newspaper is allowing to
um because you know what happened in
australia what's happening right here
and other news organizations to
combine their bargaining power this this
idea
of an app store bill some the gateway
bills i still believe and i
am i'm the author of the newspaper one
and i'm going to work really hard to get
it done this year
just like you're talking about i don't
think we can wait but the best thing
would be
to admit that we have a huge monopoly
problem here across the board and to
just put in some
stiffer rules and standards and there
was a number of republicans
right now as i speak that um are with me
on this
um to um even though they're not on my
bill yet but on pieces of that bill
to be able to make it easier
to bring these cases and that way then
some of this behavior stops even if
they're
never brought in a case because people
know that it's a real thing it's gonna
happen
uh if they keep acting like that and
that's not just mergers going forward
it's
also looking back at exclusionary
conduct
as well as some of the other violations
we've talked about senator lee do you
want to close with anything
no and thank you very much for holding
this hearing thanks to each of you for
being here
and i've been very informative right
exactly um
and our two witnesses from apple and
google do you want to
i should give you an opportunity if you
want to say anything about
legislation and the like yes senator
klobuchar
and thank you you're asking very
important questions particularly as it
relates to funding of the enforcement
agency so we'll be happy to engage with
you and other members of congress as you
work through these issues
but but before i before i wrap this
answer i'd like to say that like
each of the members on the panel here
the companies that are represented are
important partners of ours and they are
raising uh
issues from where we sit senator we're
trying to keep
at an ecosystem level we're trying to
keep the costs low for the ecosystem
and keep our our as competitive with the
numerous
distribution channels that developers
have available to them
in this very dynamic industry but i do
worry that
that may be difficult to do if in
an effort to satisfy a very small but
vocal set of primarily large companies
we damage the very foundation that has
allowed the android open source
ecosystem to work so well
for a much larger set of small and
medium-sized businesses
that that's the risk and that's what we
would want to engage with your office
and other members of congress on as you
tackle these very important questions mr
anderson
uh senator again thank you for giving us
the opportunity to participate today
and share our perspective on this when
it comes to
proposals you know i spent a decade of
my career in federal anti-trust
enforcement
both at the federal trade commission and
department of justice i have a deep
respect for what their
role is uh in their job each and every
day and an understanding of how
difficult it is
i'm certainly a supporter for doubling
tripling down
uh in terms of resources for those men
and women that carry out a really
important role each and every day
uh in terms of other issues you know
i've long appreciated your champion
of competition i recall when i was at
the ftc you raising issues around
pharmaceutical mergers and other things
that
that we took a very careful look at so
i've always been appreciative of your
interest in this area
uh and we look forward to engaging with
you in the future
okay um well this has been uh
quite informative i think for everyone
um and
um i think the facts that we've gathered
here today
are going to be useful for us for
legislation um
for uh this the justice department just
today
or this week we have uh the top two
positions filled
uh with the third one on the way in the
justice department we have uh
ftc commissioners uh being nominated
hearings i was just at a hearing in
a commerce for one of the nominees and
there's a lot happening and a lot of
interest from the administration
and so um and i do want to just tick
through this just
from from my perspective we've got a
situation where we've got the
um fees that are higher than i ever
imagined i was
looking at furniture stores and i
couldn't figure out why one major one
wasn't on the app store that was about
three weeks ago and now i understand
one weekly because they're just probably
decided i'm not going to pay this
high a fee because i thought did they do
something wrong
why aren't they why can't i access this
on my on my apple it's literally what i
thought i thought oh maybe they don't
have one do that
or maybe they just maybe i do it this
way and i i just think there's something
pretty messed up about this because as
you said it's kind of taken
over uh the internet in that way um
and the the second point is um this
idea of which we have to look further
into but self-preferencing
and uh competing um having direct
competition
of their own products and the third one
is just this idea that
consumers are literally there that um
companies are being banned from telling
consumers they can get a better deal
when they're on a monopoly the only way
they can be
on and get to those consumers in a big
way
um is through one of these um two app
stores which are on different platforms
obviously people use those platforms for
different reasons
but they each dominate uh those
platforms
and so as i hear the arguments that i've
heard today um point one
you know this argument that a lot of
them pay nothing and that's great well
that still doesn't inoculate a company
um from a liability for anti-competitive
uh conduct we just have to remember that
and there's ways you could structure
this
obviously on regulators my guests are
going to have to get involved
so you wouldn't be hurting all the uh
the small apps and the little apps out
there but you're just making this
so that people are not hurt by monopoly
conduct
um uh secondly um
we need to protect one of the arguments
we get is a security
argument more so i think from apple
lesser extent from google because it
allows
side loading um but of course we have to
protect
uh security and privacy but i think some
of the arguments here made where there's
got to be a better way to do this than a
30 percent
uh charge for it um or requiring apps to
use only your in-app payment process
or without borrowing developers from
telling consumers there's no way that
telling consumers about a cheaper rate
is going to
affect security you're just telling them
hey you can also go over to this website
third point made that the app store is
built
by them and they put incredible work
into it is true so
now they get to run it the way they want
well as been noted you know those are
the arguments
made in the past that's i'm sure what
standard oil said um
i wasn't there back then i am sure that
that
is what um uh that is what att
said for sure they had a horizontal and
a vertical
monopoly they'd put all this in they
produced all this great stuff
um i know because i represented mci
shortly after that breakup
and as they were trying to get into
local monopolies and to try to compete
in that market and i saw
despite this claim um that the world was
going to fall apart
in fact the chairman of atnt after all
this went down said they were actually a
stronger company because of it because
they were forced to compete and we saw
lower long distance rates and we also
saw uh this
incredible launch of a cell phone
industry which when you go back to the
beginning
was nothing but cell phones the size of
gordon geckos in the movie wall street
at the very beginning so
um i i just um i
i just don't think this we built it so
trust us
and we can run it it's gonna work
anymore because if you look at history
as a guide
of course people build things and they
do great things they employ a bunch of
people
and then at some point it becomes
monopoly and then it becomes a problem
as adam smith warned and then
we're supposed to be doing something
about it um without necessarily of
course
not getting rid of these companies we
want these companies
it's just a question of how you ensure
that everyone that works
that the companies that work in the are
that are present in
the capitalist system can do their their
bidding so that we actually have a
capitalist system
and so um the point number four
our app stores create jobs for many
small entrepreneurs we heard this
that's great um and those are great
things fostering innovation in that way
is
important but again it's not an
inoculation and another way you
really foster innovation is when you
allow
companies that get to a certain point
where they actually can compete we'll
never know if instagram
could have competed against facebook
because they bought them
because they viewed them as disruptive
to use mark zuckerberg's own word
um and so that's the same thing here i
don't think you can just say well just
because someone is a little more in our
line of business
day online dating compared to car rides
well that's different then or some music
or or your products with tile
um i just think that there's not a
coincidence that
uh the three of you are before us today
um because of the fact that that's
getting into
their business um and i just don't see
this differentiation as senator lee so
well pointed out
so with that i will keep the hearing
open
for two weeks
i just made that up um we'll keep this
the record open for two weeks
and we look forward to following up on
all this we thank all of our witnesses
for being with us through a lengthy
hearing
and we look forward to working with you
the hearing is adjourned
you